everybody hello hello i am back home my home this time i
sound normal now sound team does not have to freak out
anymore they're still in the basement but sound team you get
to rest easy for now but yes i'm back everybody for those
who don't know um i took a little vacation i really need
that i feel so productive right now i like i actually want
to do stuff now As in, like, I actually want to, like, not
ghost my manager for a couple.
And then, you know, like, I actually sort of, like, I, like,
I got back home.
I actually, like, answered all the stuff that the, the list
that he gave me.
I was like, bam, bam, bam, done, done, done.
I did it.
Actually was productive and actually got work done, too.
The moment I got home and everything.
Anyway, so for those who don't know, I had a little mini
vacation.
Well, I guess it is sort of mini vacation.
I really needed it.
I was so burnt out with all the events coming up and
everything.
And I came back and still did lots of stuff after it.
Rice, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Welcome back, dog.
Remember how to put your shirt back on?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway, so I, actually, I went on a cruise.
My very first cruise.
I'm fucking molting right now.
It's really gross.
Like I felt so bad But like when I was like Because like for
those who didn't know I got sunburned Really badly on my
arms And my back Because I forgot the sun For those who
didn't watch Twitch streams Because I did stream on Twitch
for a bit Because I had like a sponsor in a tournament I had
a sponsor in two tournaments Coming back And because of that
I knew I couldn't fly back to my home in time for the
sponsor so i did a midway point crashed at somebody else's
home did my sponsor and a tournament and also crashed some
collabs uh if you guys were watching sure for anything i'll
invite you to do some collabs and i was like i'm here anyway
i have a pc here so and then now i'm back home my home uh
anyway while i was like crashing at a friend's place i was
um i have my i i have not had this in a long time because
like i haven't seen the sun longer than an hour so the sun
never had the opportunity to burn me but um basically um oh
i played a bit of the peak in the big walk i didn't realize
i thought the big walk was randomly procedural generated you
know so like every experience of the big walk is different
so i did spoil myself a little bit because we are planning
on doing an actual collab collab um with some other uh with
my other friends um and so but i thought so i i stopped at
one point because i was just like i don't want to spoil
myself into because like i jumped in um in the middle of the
big walk of sure force collab because apparently we're
almost done with everything and i jumped in did a couple of
puzzles and then like um and i was just like i'm gonna stop
here also i'm very tired it's very late and because i found
out that all the puzzles stay the same i didn't realize i
thought it was like like i thought you know friend slop like
usually most friend slop games are rambly procedural
generated so i didn't realize it was just every it's just a
giant puzzle it's just a giant ass puzzle room um it's like
you're in an escape room and you're not trying to escape the
island yeah so but from what i found out is that uh for
those who don't know about the big walk um um and it's yeah
they usually go for replayability for it but it's mostly
like but i feel like after you finish the game you can't
really replay it because there's no really unless you do
like apparently the puzzles are different when you're like
duos or trios or solos so like because like each puzzle the
puzzle changes then but if you're four plus all the puzzles
stay the same and so so i was so i figured that out because
i was asking about it oh is it not randomly like no it all
stays the same until four plus so like all the puzzles so i
was just like i'm gonna stop here i don't want to spoil
myself the puzzles because uh we are planning on organizing
another vtuber collab of the big walk so i was just like i i
jumped in at the end of the game for them and then I think I
played for like two to two hours I think I don't remember
for I don't know two to three out like two hours miss made
me two hours and I was just like and they wanted to play
more and I was like okay I'll do like one more puzzle with
them like and then I was just like and I was just like I'm
done um it's an eight plus hour game it's an eight eight
plus hour puzzle game um so so there's that anyway also like
i got my uber eats order and they forgot my i was so i
really wanted to drink something and then i was so looking
forward to it i was like oh i can't wait to have my drink
with my meal and not the uber uber eats order another like
drink because they forgot the one thing they forgot was my
can of coke yeah it's like an eight plus hour puzzle game i
don't know we could finish i'm pretty sure we can't finish
this game in one day for a collab uh anyway what else yes
anyway so i was i felt so bad um because i was molting in
the pc room because i uh when i was like rubbing my arms
it's just flakes of okay it's pretty gross but flakes of
skin kept coming off and i was like oh oh this is i can't
help it i'm just i'm just dead skin on floor my dna samples
are on the floor oh it'll be a shame there's something
someone tries to clone me yeah so i do this i do this i just
rub my arm and then just get okay anyway i got sunburned um
i'm okay this is like basically i was i did my very first
cruise and i went to the bahamas because for those who
didn't watch my twitch vods um uh twitch.tv dokeybird uh or
the Apex stream, um, I, uh, I was not really planning on
doing a cruise.
I was just like, vacation!
Yay!
And then I saw a video of a cruise.
And I was just like, ooh, I've never done a cruise before.
And I was planning on doing a cruise before, but then, like,
it plans dropped because I had so many things going on.
I was like, this is the perfect time.
It's, like, still summer.
And, uh, it's, like, the end of summer.
And, which was, by the way, terrible idea to do is so many
children should have done it after summer vacation when the
kids are gone um
um anyway so i was just like and then my manager i told my
manager i was like hey i really want to do a cruise i saw a
video and i'm gonna i don't even want to do it since i'm on
vacation now and my manager was like don't do it you have a
sponsor in two tournaments the day you get back And I was
just like, oh, I already bought the tickets.
Oh, while we were talking about it, I already bought the
ticket.
So, um, I'm going on a cruise.
Yay!
And they're like, well, as long as you think you're going to
make it back in time, back at home, to do your contractual
obligations, then I trust you.
I was like, don't worry.
I'll be back at home.
That I'm not going to be back at my home.
But...
Because I calculated.
And I was just like, I won't be able to fly back at my home
in time for the sponsor.
So I need to find a midway point after the cruise.
So I can crash at somebody's place.
And then do the sponsor.
And the tournament.
And the other tournament.
And then fly back.
I can't hold it.
The loophole.
And then I was like, surprise.
And then for this to know.
I surprised my manager.
um during the stream be like hey not at home i'm at it i'm
not back at my home but i'm at a home i i was like surprise
man i was like don't wait i was like don't worry my manager
has is asleep at this time because you're european and then
he messaged me as like i am not outside i am awake right now
but the sponsor went well i mean i think it went pretty
well.
I honestly think it went well.
Didn't seem, it wasn't too bad.
Oh, it getting angry.
Also, Yosh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Welcome back, Toki.
Today is my birthday.
I'm 36 now.
I spent $500 on your merch.
Ah, thank you for the, thank you.
Thank you.
Have a happy birthday for my Oshi.
Of course you can.
Yosh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
thank you and thank you again for um for getting toky
merchants expanding your toky shrine what a great birthday
present to me and to you anyway happy birthday to you happy
birthday to you happy birthday dear yosh happy birthday to
you yeah happy birthday we had a great birthday the best
part about being adult is that is the disposable income like
me when i'm use my money to buy to go on a cruise by the way
i did not realize that cruises was such a white person thing
i swear to god i did not realize what do you don't get what
do you mean by that i i think i saw like five asians on the
cruise it was like i swear i saw like all different types
all different types of races but there was only I think I
only saw five Asians I think there were more Asian staff
than there were Asian passengers I did not realize yeah I
didn't I didn't realize it was like a huge it was like uh
really I guess like a a white person pastime to do cruises I
was like talking like you know people were so friendly there
um people people were so friendly like you would be in an
elevator and they'll like talk to you and i was just like
okay cool so like you know they just want yeah this is my
fifth cruise and i was just like oh my god like they're like
yeah this is my fifth cruise i have the membership and
everything and i was like damn this is like a culture for
you guys, is it?
Jay Lakon, thank you for magenta soup, thank you, thank you.
Poor Manzan, I hope the cruise was worth their suffering.
By the way, fellow dragon could not make it to it, but it's
their birthday.
Can you wish our fellow dragon still not a bird, Kurosus?
Oh, it's Kurosus's birthday?
Of course I can!
Happy birthday, Kurosus!
Even though you haven't been here right now, if you're
watching the VOD, happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Croesus happy birthday to you yeah
happy birthday and thank you for the magenta soup thank you
thank you um but yeah I I did not I was like I was just like
wow at first I was like am I the only Asian on this cruise
like and I was like every time I see another Asian person on
it I was like you like oh same hat you know we're like oh my
god same hat We're the same.
I don't know.
I just felt like, whoa.
Hey, Toki.
Welcome back.
It was my birthday week ago.
While you're awake, can you get happy?
Of course.
Of course, I need ketchup on the birthday wishes from the...
I feel like I'm still there.
My brain is still there in the Bahamas right now.
Lolly, thank you for Super Chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Dear Lolly, happy birthday to you.
Yeah, happy birthday, everybody.
Birthday, Lolly.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, we're, what are they going to say?
But yeah, anyway.
But yeah, the cruise went to the Bahamas and back.
Okay, terrible timing, by the way.
I was so mad.
But, you know how I said, like, so, you know, like, the
blood moon.
occurred like after I bought the cruise tickets so I
fortunately I couldn't do the water parks um I couldn't do
the water parks on the islands because like I don't know I
don't want to scare some kids like also the fact that it's
very unhygienic you know but but it's okay on the last two
days of the cruise it stopped on the last two days of the
cruise it stopped um so but like on one of the days was when
we actually get to go to the water park and i was so fucking
sad i was like oh yeah shark week by the way but like you
know also i didn't want to go to the ocean while i'm while
there's blood everywhere because i i don't i don't know we
all shark week and predators can smell blood for miles and
miles away so i was just like all right maybe i shouldn't
risk my life for a little bit of the ocean um but on the
last days i did get to experience the bahama ocean though
that's how i got sunburned um but oh yeah i also never
bought fancy shoes i'm jumping in between a lot of stories
right now but i also never bought fancy because there was
like one of the things you could do on the cruise ship is to
go to like a fancy one of the fancy restaurants and it was
like there's a dress code and everything i was like you know
i was like at that point i was like i'm gonna see if i can
buy shoes on the cruise because i was just like i don't have
time
i was just like maybe i'll buy shoes on the cruise if i have
to and then by then i was like You know, I'm gonna check,
I'm gonna see how strict the, uh, how strict the dress code
is for this.
Mr. Muflofikens, thank you for Super Chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki, I have a round one matchup against an evil winner
for Street Fighter.
CEO, the attorney you have gone to.
Have you won with Shad?
Wish me not if I will.
I think there was no odds of us actually winning that.
Wish me, look, I'm scared.
Mr. Muflofikens, thank you for Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll just take one just if you if you take even like one set
one like one round off of him you win you won basically it's
a moral victory like he has everything to lose you have
nothing to lose also bring a dokey plushie too to be like if
you do take a round up be sure to be like yeah so it's like
I also took a round off you know so it's almost like I was
there He took a round off.
Yeah, it's a moral win.
Yeah, take a round off and then one and done him.
Just leave.
He wins.
He wins automatically.
But he didn't earn the win.
Yeah, take the round off and then just unplug and leave.
Just...
Yeah, it's a man.
That's gonna fuck with his head.
You know it.
You know that's gonna fuck with him.
Mr. McFluff begins.
Thank you, Mr. Super Chat.
Thank you.
Doki plushie and Kasa shirt already.
Nice!
I can't wait.
He wins the war, but not the battle.
I think that's so...
That's going to hit him hard.
He's going to remember that.
It's going to be five years later, and he's going to
remember you unplugging him live on land.
Like...
Because he didn't earn that victory.
too yeah anyway so um so there was like a fancy uh the fancy
there was like a fancy dinner place and i was just like how
strict is this dress code so because i was like bro it's
everyone's on vacation right now no one wants to dress fancy
right everybody's in the hawaiian shirts and everything and
like with flip-flops and sandals so i went down to like the
fans the quote-unquote restaurant area I legit I saw people
in like flip-flops and like shorts because they're like no
shorts and I was like okay I all I packed were shorts I
packed one long pants so and I literally saw people and I
was wearing crocs too by the way I was wearing crocs and
shorts like I was I was enjoying my vacation
And then, yeah, and so I was just like, I looked at it, and
then I literally saw people, like, saw like, you know, like
the, you know, the 60 year old vacation dad in their shorts,
short sandals and Hawaiian shirt.
And I was like, all right, I don't need to buy shoes.
Like, I don't need to buy any fucking fancy ass shoes.
And I just walked in with my Crocs shorts and unfortunately
not Hawaiian shirt.
a shirt on that says don't stress me out like yeah so so
yeah it's just enjoying my time all right i did wrote
everything that oh yeah by the way i got sunburned because i
forgot to um i forgot that uh you know when i i don't know
why okay look guys it's been a while since i've seen the
ocean I talked about this before on the Twitch VOD, but like
you don't understand in Canada our beaches are just
technically a beach like Our beaches are just a technicality
if anything our beaches are just like giant lakes that just
has salt water in them Like we're just the Canadian geese
roam is like Canadian geese like territory So our Canadian
beaches are very sad They're they're very very very sad.
So um It's it's we're just it's it's it is a beach It's sort
of a beach.
It's technically a beach, but not actually a beach So you
know how like you see all those like stock photos?
Yeah quote-unquote beach I can't believe it's not butter.
You know like
Anyway so I thought you know the stock photos you see of
like actual beaches where the water is like clear blue and
you can sort of like canadian beaches you can't see through
the water like it's just it's like those dark gloomy blue
you're gonna drown in those oceans type water when you see a
canadian beach so like it's not clear you don't see through
shit or whatever but then like you know those stock photos
yeah i can't believe it's a beach yeah you know those stock
photos of beaches like bahama be like Like the one behind me
right now was clear blue.
You can sort of, you can see your feet when you're in the
waters and everything.
I thought that was like Photoshop.
I didn't.
I didn't realize they're real.
Like, you know, I thought it was just like movie magic type
deal.
Where, like, I thought like, it's like they're a myth.
It's like movie magic.
I didn't realize like oh my this actually exists in real
life so when I was there I was like oh my god like you know
how like in swimming pools like the way just like all I like
majority of time I've never actually been in a real beach
before by the way I've like been on in swimming pools like
indoor swimming pools like like those types of clear fucking
blue ass water you know how like swimming pools how they get
the water to be that color it's because they paint the
bottom of the pool itself blue so the water looks blue if
you paint the swimming pool i don't know if you've ever seen
a video of it but you paint like the swimming pool like the
the tiles and everything black the water will come out as
black so like you can even paint it as red if you want to
fuck with people like if you have if you own a personal
swimming pool and you you can technically paint the tiles
red just to fuck with your neighbors or hide a body I don't
know like they'll never know it's red they'll commit a
murder in this way if they'll never know it's red like
that's just a joke by the way this joke do not do that you
know I'll be like I got my idea like like uh Dragoon got
caught for murder by fucking painting their swimming pool
tiles red I'm like I got my idea from watching a dokeybird
stream please do not do that um say you got an idea from
someone else's stream but not me um because like i can't
what i'm gonna do i don't make a stop that like but also do
not do that for for legal reasons it's a joke but that's how
swimming pools um got get the clear blue color um if you're
ever like a personal swimming pool or indoor swimming pool
or whatever like outside i don't know fucking a swimming
pool of chlorine and everything um that's how it's blue
because they paint the tiles blue so you can technically
make it red you can technically make your water red you
paint it red like that's just like crazy move that's that's
what i see like you know movie magic so i didn't realize
like that type of ocean exists in real life like like i let
me i took photos of it let me also my drink's gonna be here
i haven't eaten like i only took a couple bites of my food
because i was so thirsty um Let's see, let me see.
I took a couple of photos of it.
I'll grab it off of Twitter because I know I got it off of
Twitter.
Well, thank you.
This is too late.
Thank you.
I just ordered seven cans of red paint.
All right, let's see.
Let me get this picture of the way.
Oh, oh, my drink's here.
All right.
Let me download this So I can give you guys visuals And what
I mean Let's see For legal reason Doki Bird gave me the
craziest color To paint the locals What do people Go man,
thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you So like I
didn't think this was real Like this is what I mean Like I
was just like Oh my Water can come In this color I was just
like oh my god when you water like exists in this color I'm
like naturally it's not movie magic oh my that's great I
like it blew my mind realizing that that's a real that's a
real color in the ocean I was like oh my god I'm not, it's
not a movie.
It's actually real.
Um, oh, sorry, I don't have any better pictures, by the way,
of the, this is the best picture I have, because we went to
two, uh, islands on the cruise.
The cruise took me to, like, two different islands.
One is in, like, in the Bahamas, and then one is a private
island, I guess, in the Bahamas.
Like, okay, they're both in the Bahamas, but, like, I wish I
had a better photo of the other beach that was in but like a
giant thunderstorm happened like I didn't realize this but
in Miami like like thunderstorms are very common are very
common in Miami like it just happens out of nowhere they'll
be like you'd see the storm clouds coming in too which is
crazy to see I like looked up and I was like, I think it's
good.
I was just like, wow, that's a lot of gray clouds coming
towards me.
I was like, so this is like on one of the good days where
there wasn't a thunderstorm.
I'll show you like a photo of like, you could tell like it's
coming.
Like, you know, like, oh, the thunderstorm's coming.
I'll show you here.
Yeah, it moves so fast.
So I, I, it's like, and then like a giant like um like giant
like lots of rain too i was kind of middle of it but like
you could tell the difference so this is like this drain
like post thunder like you'd see you'd tell where like the
storm is approaching by the way if you look at the right
side that's where all the gray clouds were like so on the
right we're all the Greek yeah it was like slowly heading
towards me so I didn't get to take photo of like of like the
other beach because I forgot because I was just fucking
relaxed I was on vacation man yeah yeah I was on vacation I
was not taking a lot of photos I was just like enjoying like
okay so I was keeping uh it's always an hurricane season I
did not even realize that not a great time to the Bahamas,
by the way.
Nuppers, thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
Also, my drink should be here soon, so I'm going to check
the door real quick.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'm back, and I got my drink, too.
Alright, do I order two, so I can put one in the fridge.
Do I drink the... Oh, oh, fuck.
Okay, give me a sec.
I have tissues.
Actually, I'll drink the mango slushy.
It's like I'm still there.
It's like, it's like I'm still there in the Bahamas.
she all right all right so i got sunburned because um i
haven't put sunscreen on within maybe like 10 plus years by
the way um because like i said i don't go out in the sun
like you know one hour in this like less than an hour i
usually do less than an hour in the sun because i'm always
inside like there was no reason to ever put sunscreen for me
because i'm always i'm very pale like because I'm always
inside so like what you know what's the point
and so so basically I was so confused because like you know
10 years ago you know my mom would just give me sunscreen
and I'm just like I just put it on so never like bought my
own sunscreen so I didn't know what the numbers mean like
what do the numbers mean like I had to like, you know,
you're like, ah, do you want the 30 or the 80 or this?
I was like, ah, what higher the number, the better?
I don't know.
In my head, my logic is the higher the number, the better it
is.
Like, I just went with that.
Like, so, but I didn't think the most it had was 80.
Um.
And I had to Google it and be like, what do the numbers mean
on sunscreen?
I don't know!
I just be like, what do you know?
I was like, okay, there's 30 or 80.
I assume 80 is better.
A bigger number means better.
I don't know.
That's my logic.
Because I was like, it was more expensive.
So it should technically be better.
I don't know.
Or I'm getting scammed.
Usually maybe I'm getting scammed.
Because like, because usually that's where you can get the
tourists.
You know, that's how they get you.
They see big numbers and that's how they get to
Anyway, I was like, Bob, SPF 80 And then, I don't know, this
is so fucking stupid I was like, I got everything I got
everywhere, I got the back of, I got my legs, my arms My
face And then like And then the thing is I forgot the sun is
not whichever direction you're facing the sun got you the
sun is like 360 you know because the earth is I don't know
you guys know this but the earth is round so the sun rays
are 360 around yeah they hit you 360 no scope so um I when I
was like on the beach I would I was my belly because I was
just like you know I got like a floaty and I took a nap
which is also you can tell the mistakes are piling up you
know so it was so relaxing but like I didn't it's not like I
would drift off to the fucking middle of the ocean it's like
there's a lot you know I assume there's a lot of like
important people on cruises sometimes like people with a lot
of money I don't think they'll like let that happen up
I don't think like They're gonna let this random girl Just
drift off into the middle of the ocean Let the tides take me
So I put a lot of trust on the lifeguards here I thought it
was like a gate I thought it seemed like It's like a gated
community You know So So anyway I got floaty Like there was
like You know there was like floaties and like Grass and
stuff that you can lean on or like rest on so i got floaty
and then i like lean on on my belly like just with my arms
like just hanging there on the floaty like you know like the
center equilibrium and stuff so i'm just like floating there
i took a nap because it was so relaxing it really was um and
and i'll and i don't know how a lot i was napping for i was
just floating out there um i just assumed because like also
like there was like a curfew being like you have to make
sure to get back on by 5 p.m.
or to leave like we're gonna leave so but then we're also on
like another island or something because we have to take a
mini boat to this other island to get to this to this island
with the sea lions and the dolphins and everything by the
way I did sea lion shit it's actually really fun I think sea
lions were more fun than I didn't get to do with the
dolphins because they were sold out um I gotta do the sea
lions also didn't get to take any photos of the sea lion
conservation area so
so they gotta make their money so they're like no photos but
you can buy our photos type deal to fund the fund the
conservation shit um
I mean to be fair I said this on Twitch but I think I made a
better choice this dolphin you know instead of um you know I
saw sea lions you know the dogs of the ocean versus seeing
like the Epstein would you like to pet the dog or meet
Epstein like the sexual predators of the ocean like so I
think I made the better I made the better choice I whoa the
what for those who don't know um this is like this is
because of the propaganda Dolphin propaganda.
Hashtag not all dolphin.
Yeah.
So, for those who don't know, who got lied by Big Dolphin.
Wildfoot tramp.
Dolphins are the sexual predators of the ocean.
They're not actually as nice as you think they are.
The crazy part is she's not real.
wrong um so they if you ever looked up on like what do
dolphins do in the wild they do a lot of things in the wild
uh release the dolphin files um they you know okay so like
they're very sexually active and it does not consent does
not matter to them that's the best i can describe Dolph,
they're, they're freaky ass, they're freaky as fuck, and
they do not care.
Not all dolphins, but always a dolphin.
Is there like the perverts of the ocean?
If you're like, no way, they've done, they've done, okay,
so, you know how dolphins have blowholes?
You know how other animals have blowholes?
They see a hole.
Oh, and they also do drugs.
I forgot about that.
They will get high if given a choice.
Yeah, all they see is a hole.
They don't care what kind of hole.
And also, they do love to get high.
So, so yeah, anyway, I saw the sea lions instead of the
dolphins.
I think I made it better.
It was actually very cute.
Stop.
Oh, yeah.
And they bully shark.
They do.
I've seen videos like they don't care.
They don't fucking care.
Yeah.
Um.
So, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry I have to ruin your perfect image of a dolphin.
Like the top.
I'm sorry.
Like, I have to get rid of the dolphin propaganda here.
hmm anyway so um it was so they were so cute the sea lions
um so um i did like a photo there was like you have there
was like a photo shoot portion not everything was money
every like um i realized like i realized like cruises are
like a way to milk as much money as possible from you um so
i think I did spend a lot of money But like I tried not to
spend too much money So like for like restaurants and stuff
Because there's like free complimentary restaurants And
there's like restaurants where you pay I went to the buffet
like majority of the time I was on the cruise Because like I
think I did pay for some meals But it was because there was
like one restaurant I went to That was fucking crazy It was
like There was a theme restaurant that I went to That I did
pay for comped a little bit um okay from the art like the
auction area there because i spent money on fucking muhammad
ali's boxer trunks so they comped they like basically that
meal was technically free because they comp for it um anyway
so there was a themed restaurant called wonderland and it
was like you know this experimental oh yeah by the way i
bought muhammad ali's uh signed boxer trunks
i'll get into more of that later um they tried to like
you're like they thought it was like muhavan ali's biggest
fan so like they're like there was like they showed me this
portrait this apparently like um collaboration that he's
done with the modern day picasso what is his name well i
don't i don't know i'm not i'm sorry if this is if the
auction people our gallery people are watching i'm so sorry
i'm they thought i was a huge art nerd but i was just like
this i'd stumbled my way into the art gallery I was like
trying to find a casino.
So, it was like the modern day Picasso.
What is his name?
I don't know.
I forgot.
But it's like, um, uh, what was the guy's name?
That says any art gallery, art people.
Are there any art people?
Yeah, I'm actual LARPing right now.
Not Banksy.
thinks he's not Picasso.
It's like works are, his works aren't like Picasso, like
modern day, I'm just gonna Google, modern day Picasso.
Who's still alive?
Like he's still alive, by the way.
Oh my God.
Picasso, Muhammad.
Like he did like a collaboration with this guy what is his
name i'm trying to remember um
god what the was his name i'm sure it's not picasso is
someone picasso's dead it can't be it can't be modern day
picasso if he's dead like a guy that's still alive
let's see I don't remember anyway I didn't buy it it was
like apparently like 30 grand and I was just like I'm not I
was like literally straight up told him I was just like I'm
not I was like I'm not like the biggest Muhammad Ali fan I
thought it was super interesting and and I was just like I
was like I like collecting weird like not weird stuff but
like but like uh yeah no I didn't I was just like, oh,
that's three like Apparently it was like in the storage They
had to they got it out of storage Cause it was like on the
last day And they got it out of storage Just to show it to
me And I took a picture of it I took a picture of it That
was really cool Cause it was like a one of one Not like a
printer or anything I double checked and everything Because
I looked at the Um Oh, sorry, Peter Max Peter Max That's his
name that's not it it was Peter Max that's his name I'm not
getting like let me see if I can grab the photo I took a
photo of it um let's see who guys we're not art gallery
people it's okay to not know it
so so my got it out of like storage just to show it to me
and it was like 30 grand um because it wasn't like displayed
or anything it was like locked up or some shit um i don't
know they were like modern day picasso peter max and i was
just like it's cool i took a picture of it i was like it's
almost the same thing it's like it's all like owning it you
know okay let me see I can find a picture I took it yeah
it's almost like owning owning one alright this one's not it
okay I'm trying to all right let me second okay I need to
all right I'll show you guys the picture Yeah, it's like...
I did...
I was like...
Um...
Copy and paste, it's mine now.
I took a screenshot.
I did.
I took a screenshot of it and be like, it's almost like a...
Like, it's almost like having it.
Uh...
I right clicked a real life painting.
I did.
I...
Um...
Alright, let me see.
Oh, yeah, by the way, I also got myself another cruise for
free.
Um, I think I assumed they want the, because I bought the
Muhammad Ali, uh, the Muhammad Ali boxer trunks and also the
American Eagle statue.
I had to get it.
Okay, so this one I looked it up myself.
Um, basically, um, the guy is dead.
So, like, the sculpture guy, the guy who made the sculpture,
I'll show you guys that.
I think it was so fucking cool.
Like, I didn't care about anything else there.
I saw the sculpture.
That's the one that, like, caught my eye.
And I looked up the artist and everything.
Let me show you guys.
I showed you guys a picture of it.
So, I bought the sculpture and the trunks.
So, then they were, like, they gave me a free...
Any cruise I want to go to.
I was like, even a Disney cruise, even a Disney cruise.
So, um, let me see.
Let me see if I can grab it.
Whoa, what?
So I got free cruise.
I got free cruise to anywhere I want.
A Zonderman.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Trader.
Watch.
No, the thing is, next thing, I thought I knew that that was
the plan.
I knew that was the plan, but legit, I was just like, I was
like, but you know, I can tell that was the plan but like I
know but I stopped right there next to you think it was
super chat thank you thank you I stopped right there I was
like free cruise is a free cruise baby
but I'll take the free cruise I'll take it
All right, but let me second show you guys the, where is it?
I'm trying to remember where the picture was, and it was
here.
All right, this one.
I saw this.
I'm trying to remember the artist's name.
Let's see.
Uh...
Bam.
Oh, okay.
It's like bronze statue.
Don't worry, Nexi.
I read up about it.
Don't worry.
I'll take the free cruise, though.
Freedom isn't free.
So, this is a sick-ass... What do you mean, hideous?
I thought it was...
It's made as a bronze statue.
I thought it looked sick as hell.
And the guy's dead, too.
So, I was like, sweet.
I mean, not...
sweet the fact that the guy's dead but you know it's like he
can't really make another one like you know because he's
dead not because he's you know i'm not saying sweet because
he's dead but but i meant like he can't make more you know
so hmm um and i was like i wasn't like interested in their
paintings obviously and more i think like the statues was
the thing that caught my eye the most and like i read about
it because i was just like there was another one that was
really cool but parents made by his son so it's like not the
same you know like apparently it's because he's passed away
um his son took over his business because i read up about it
and like it was explained me too and there was like stat
obviously like it's not the same as it may be made by this
guy um and his son made a really cool one but it's just like
it's not like the original sculptor you know so um and his
works are actually displayed uh like i look i read his wiki
guys i i read his wikipedia guy okay there was one that was
really cool let me see i'm trying to remember his name
uh there was his work is displayed in the white house and
also like at Vatican City and stuff but like he has like a
bunch of his statues in the white house because it's a
fucking American eagle like like it's it's a fucking it's
the American he it's literally just USA that's not I'm not
surprised displayed in the fucking white house like so that
so there's like this one statue that I saw.
That was really fucking cool.
I'm trying to see if I, it was like, I didn't get that one.
That one was crazy expensive.
Like that.
Oh my god, I think it's this one.
It's literally, it's on, oh my god, it's literally in the
oval office.
Wait, oh my god.
Yes, okay.
I didn't even realize it was like in the oval office type
deal, but it looks like this, but it's not covered in
Okay, so it was like, it looked like this, basically.
But it wasn't covered in gold.
It was, but it was in bronze.
Not in gold, though, but in bronze.
It literally looked just, it looked like this.
Okay, it was this.
I saw this.
It was this bronze version.
Yeah, no, I didn't want, it was, but it looked cooler.
bronze it was like this but like uh let's see there was a
better version of this let me see okay this one this is
better it looked like this i thought it was pretty sick but
i didn't get it because it was so expensive it was like i
got the american flag i think the bronze was looks really
cool The gold one, a little bit too.
A little too, what's the word?
A little too goddy, I guess.
A little too much.
It's too much.
Yeah, the bronze one looks so much better.
And that was the one I saw.
And I was like, I was tempted to get that or the American
flag one.
But I thought it was funnier.
I thought the, you know, it's like this was the Declaration
of Independence.
But I thought the American, yeah, tacky.
It looks a little too tacky.
The gold version.
But I got the...
I got the American flag one only because I thought it'd be
funny That's the first thought I was like it's funnier as a
Canadian to own the American flag one And that was my
initial thought when I was like oh, yeah, I should get this
also because I thought I looked sick as hell Like I mean it
does look fucking sick as hell
I'm sorry, but that shit looks fucking fire.
It's more American than some.
Oh yeah, and I put like, Tim, I put like some, a Canadian,
like a RCMP hat on top of the fucking eagle, and now I have
a different message.
You know?
The symbolism changes after that.
Yeah, and I have a minion nendroid at the bottom, like, next
to the flag.
hard.
I don't know.
I just thought it goes hard.
So I own that, too.
Uh, the process of dokey.
I don't know.
I just, I just thought it goes, it looks sick as hell.
Hmm.
I only bought two things.
And that's like, the only thing I spent money on.
Yes.
Almost anything, it's me.
Solid snake thing is a super chat.
Thank you.
And it's a bird.
It's a bird.
Okay.
It's a bird too.
Anyway, all right.
Let me start the story from the beginning.
But yeah, anyway, I forgot about sunburn.
But yeah, basically I forgot to fucking put sunscreen on my
back because I'm a fucking idiot.
You can be described as I'm just a fucking idiot.
And so my entire back got burned.
I'm like literally molting right now from my arms.
um yeah a lot of stories short all right i wrote everything
down let me check my little my little notebook of stuff i've
done um let's see if i didn't blow my nose
i'm gonna sell my sushi too
it's okay i'm not in pain anymore so i think that's the
positive it only it was like day one day one of the sunburn
was where i start feeling painful
i let me have my last piece of sushi and then i can tell the
full story of my vacation i still feel like i'm vacationing
right now me back to the Bahamas baby it was nice it was
actually so relaxing oh yeah I'm going out of order on
everything I went to a silent disco or silent part like I
don't know I guess that's what they called a silent disco
toga party on there it was on the last day it was so I never
I've, you know, I've always heard about the silent, because
I know, like, silent discos are silent, um, what's it
called?
Club?
Silent clubs?
Hmm.
So there is a no, no.
The silent music clubs are very popular in Europe, I
believe, right?
They're very popular in Europe because, um, of, like, music
laws, you know, like sound, like, uh, what's the word
called?
Like, noise levels and noise, noise control laws.
and stuff in Europe.
So they're very, very popular back there.
But I know they're not very popular in NA because they were
like, if we're gonna get like what's it called?
Tendonitis?
Is this called Tendonitis?
Or Tendonitis?
I don't know.
You're like, when you just can't hear anymore.
Like, wee!
What's the word called?
I always get confused with the other T word.
Tendonitis?
Oh, yeah, like in N.A., like people just tank that shit.
Like, they're like, who cares about the health of your
fucking ears?
Who actually wants to hear, guys?
Like, we take tinnitus, like, men.
Hell, yeah.
We fucking take that shit.
Which is very bad.
Yeah, I have the freedom to destroy my ears.
USA.
The USA.
Yeah, I worry about that when I'm 70.
And I can't hear anything after.
You only live once.
Anyway, that's like, but in Europe, in Europe, I read that.
I know like silent music clubs or silent discos is like, or
like 40, you're right.
40 is when it hits you.
Yeah, I'm here to listen to drop the bass.
Anyway, so, oh, tendonitis or tendonitis.
Oh, sorry, I meant tendonitis, whatever.
This is a T word.
Anyway, so in Europe, it's very popular.
of noise control like you know they want to make sure that
people stay healthy with their ears and also the noise noise
curfew and noise control laws and all that shit uh you guys
did especially in germany um anyway so um during the last
day of the cruise uh they had some music parties and clubs
and everything on the last day you know everybody's gonna
fucking get drunk even though like to get off the cruise is
seven in the morning so i was just like it's crazy like
people are fucking like yeah party but then we have to leave
the cruise at seven in the morning in the morning so um
anyway so i went to the i was curious because i've never
actually went to a silent disco before uh i never went to a
silent disco disco before so um so i decided i didn't go to
the other music club but i don't know i think it's sad to go
there by myself but then it was sad to go to the silent
anyway and also i was like maybe dangerous late at night
like to go to a like the music club or whatever the
non-silent one There's a silent one and there's a non-silent
one.
So for those who don't know what a silent music club is or a
silent club or silent disco, it's basically, instead of, oh,
it's so fucking cringe.
It's so funny because it was at the top of the deck and I
got in the elevator and I got, and then I got out.
I was like, I think this is where the silent disco is.
I looked in and it was the saddest thing I've ever seen.
It was, I'm so sorry.
It was so sad.
So, there's like a bunch of people wearing headphones and
the music is playing through the headphones, but like, um,
but it's like you don't hear, like, obviously when you don't
have the headphones, you don't hear what's going on, you
know?
So, it's like, I walked in and then I just see like a bunch
of people just shimmy around, like it's not even a lot of
people, too.
There was someone made like a circle.
It was just just shimmying around to the music that they're
listening to on their headphones.
It was so awkward to see.
It was so awkward.
It was I was just I was like, this is the silence.
Okay.
I was just like, oh, this is pretty dumb.
You know, like the music circle and shit.
But and the thing is, I didn't know about this part about
the headphones.
It's that it plays two different types of music so so some
of them aren't even dancing to the same song because there's
two tracks that you can swap to and so i've only found that
out because i put on the headphones myself so this is like i
got this from google so it's like so you can see the blue
and greens right the blue and green color by the way it's
not that many people it's just like maybe 10 like maybe like
15 people 15 to 20 people were there but um so like the
green oh so like one of them was like rmb and the other one
was like latino music like i don't know i was just like so
one track was yeah one track was rmb and the other one was
like latina music and i was just like like like spanish
music and i was just like And you'd see who's on whom so you
see like a circle people on different music tracks just that
the circle dancing the it was so weird it was
Yeah, and then yeah, it's just like people are it was it was
so weird because I haven't I didn't have the headphones yet
Because I'd go and get the headphones on and just see like
yeah Just and then like there's some people just sleeping on
the cruise like the beach chairs and stuff and with the
headphones on.
And I was like, this is not a party.
Yeah, there's live music and then R&B.
And I was just like, and some people were just like, we're
just sleeping on the couches with the headphones on.
This was an 18 plus event, by the way.
And I was just like, oh, this is so, I literally got in, put
the headphones on.
People watched for like two minutes.
and then left.
I was just like, I could not be there.
So, yeah, I was just like, oh, no, this is weird.
I do not, I don't know.
I don't fuck with silent discos.
I know.
You guys, thank you.
Thank you.
On one side, people just nodding their heads on the other
end, macaroni.
Thank you.
That's true.
If I was drunk But I was way too sober.
So I was definitely judging.
Also, do not gamble.
Guys, do not gamble.
I understand now how casinos get you.
I told you guys, I have a problem.
I never IRL gambled until that day.
Do not gamble.
If there was no adult karaoke, I would have stayed.
there I wanted to go to karaoke so I luckily I got I I like
putting the the siren pull I shook off the siren pull
because I was like oh karaoke but oh my I could have stayed
there I oh my god I I put a hundred dollars in the slots and
it was all gone it was it was and i was like yeah i
legitimately was like i'm having so much fun yeah i was just
like boom boom boom ah oh i did it i got it was like three
dollars oh my god it was three dollars and it was gone i
might have lost 150 dollars 50 from blackjack a hundred on
slots i do not and then i i do not i saw a lady um because
they're all on your fucking cruise card too cyber think of a
super chat thank you thank you do not gamble and i think it
was like less than 15 minutes because i was just doing slots
it goes by so fast um no i i get i get it i know i get it
you know i was like always i always like oh i've never
gambled i because i know if they get me they're gonna get me
they're gonna
I, I, I, oh, the blind boxes got me.
I don't, I will not be surprised if other shit got me.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But that's the only thing I've learned from you, Toki.
Let it ride.
So, um, so I did blackjack for the first time.
And, um, and, you know, like hit me, you know, because I was
just like, oh, it's 21, you know?
And I, and it was just, oh.
the rush by the way does that I'm not trying to convince you
to do anything guys, guys, guys, it's so really, whoa, dude,
that sounds so fun let me also do a play.
That's not what I'm trying to imply.
Dude whoa, dude, I want to feel that rush too.
Let me go to my nearby.
No, that's not what I'm trying.
I'm not encouraging anything.
I'm not encouraging anyone to do anything.
And don't keep her voting.
Guys, I lost my money, guys.
Guys, I lost my money.
Yeah, black chat's so fucked.
Don't do it.
Chargoos, don't stop before you hit the thing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
X factor.
Super chat.
Thank you.
How did you...
Not learned.
Also, I just got my Doki Watson plushie.
I got three Doki plushies and one Doki figure.
Yeah, I've got those Doki Watson plushies.
All right, I'm now.
Thank you, Mr. Richard.
Thank you, thank you.
But it'll be the last, guys, I swear to God.
I just wanted to know what it was like.
I've never been to a casino before.
Also, I saw a lady with 32,000 credits.
I have no idea how much money that is in.
Because it was, like, in credits.
So, I was just like, Jesus, you practically live here.
So can we expect another ToraBus stream soon, right?
We're always thinking of a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I mean, ToraBus different, guys.
ToraBus different, guys.
It's not the same.
At least you win something in return.
Anyway, okay, yeah.
Oh, funny story.
um a very famous baseball player um was i i was like when i
was boarding the plane um because i had to do a transfer i
had to transfer to miami i couldn't do it one way so when i
was boarding the plane um it was so weird it was so i was so
crazy but it was like I think it was around the time I think
what was it called it was like a very famous baseball player
I think they're from Atlanta Atlanta Braves I don't know
anyone know baseball who would be like oh my god it's the
Atlanta Braves so it was literally like post Atlanta Braves
match or some shit that was heading to Miami and it was
crazy because like um I I
something illegal or some shit because um um uh i when i was
like i was like behind the guy i was behind the guy and then
he scanned his ticket and then um and then the guy like when
he won't the guy like the baseball player went into went i'm
sorry my i'm still in the bahamas right now all right i'm
just having a stroke like i'm mentally just still there i'm
anyway so um so he like went to board the plane and then the
ticket guy the this oh no the guy that handles the ticket
station or whatever i'm not even trying anymore i was just
like fill in the blanks I was like, Dragalus, you fill in
the blanks on what I'm trying to say.
Like, you look up the Doki Dictionary.
And so, the ticket guy, the ticket guy, was like, wait,
stop, come back.
And I was like, oh, my God, oh, my God, did he, oh, was he
trying to sneak into the plane?
Oh, my God, does he have a bomb?
Oh, what is he stopping him for?
coming back he's already passed the door and so and the guy
came back obviously he's like what the and then and then the
the air attendant i guess the flight attendant i guess you
do our flight attendants i also was like hey nice save
yesterday and i was just like what
I was just like, oh my God, I thought this guy had a bomb.
What do you mean?
Looking nice.
You call this guy back just to say that.
Yeah, it's legit.
He's like, wait, come back.
Hey.
And then the guy literally is like, nice save yesterday.
And yeah, so it was a guy.
It was a guy that did that.
yeah and so and i was like who the fuck is this guy in front
of me and i was like and i realized he was wearing like
louis like he was like decked out in designer clothes and
like designer bag yeah louis vuitton suitcase and everything
and then like like studs earrings and everything and i don't
know it was scary it was scary he was so it was like he was
really like serious about like being like hey come back here
like you know like you know shit like that so obviously i
was What did he do?
And why did he pull him back?
And I realized, wait, he was wearing a hat with the MLB
baseball logo on it.
And then I was just like, oh, wait, this guy's a baseball
player.
And then I don't remember who, I don't even remember which
guy he was.
I remember looking him up.
I was like, I think it's this guy.
yeah so so i was just like i think it's him like i don't
fucking know it could i just knew he was in the atlanta
braves because his backpack had the logo of the atlanta
braves and he had like a baseball hat on so i assumed he was
in the atlanta braves and he was sitting in first class like
i was behind first class i was like in the economy plus
because i was just like i'm checking i need a nice i was
just like i wanted to i wanted to like go to the lounge yeah
so i paid an extra 50 you know there's like because i was
tired from the transfer i was like like because it was a
long there was a long intermission between the transfers so
i was just like i'm gonna go to the lounge and chill before
my flight like yes i paid an extra 50 to have the economy
plus tickets like sit in the fucking lounge yeah because i
was like i didn't fucking long transfer right so i was
behind first class so i knew he was in first class um but i
don't know which player he was i fucking just breathed the
same air as this guy like
Technically I met him Technically he was right in front of
me By the way Yeah I breathe I was in his like Fucking
proximity Don't know who he is He's in the Atlanta Braves
Don't know Don't know who he is But he's in the Atlanta
Braves Basically like In his breathing space Like I I was in
i breathe the same air as him did she yeah i don't even know
which player it is guys apparently did a cool save that day
so like he's someone very important yeah who had that really
nice save that's all my that's all the context i know close
enough
i can't believe it i know don't worry guys it's okay Atlanta
Braves Atlanta Braves players it's one of them one of these
players was in front of me I oh my god there's so many
players I don't wait a minute there's so many players which
one could it be I don't even which okay it can't be a
pitcher right so it's one of the fielders so one of these
guys all right okay I'm going to cross okay so it's one of
these guys
one of them that's all I could remember one of these guys
maybe I shouldn't circle it
it's one of them these guys I was in their proximity one of
these guys they were there I don't know I I mostly saw the
back guys like I said this guy was in front of me so all I
could see was the back and the little bit of like the side
profile like it's one of them like wait do pictures also I
don't fucking know the guy said nice save out there and I
just assume it's like the fielders I don't know I don't know
the pictures do that shit too it's one of them
Who did?
Oh, yeah, because they're like, why aren't you with the
team?
And he's like, I'm vacation, baby.
Beard.
He had a beard.
He had a beard, guys.
It's John Facebook.
Yeah, the dude was like, the flight attendant was like, why
aren't you with the team?
It's like, I'm on vacation.
My vacation just started.
That does nothing.
I know.
Just know it could be any of them.
It's one of them.
Um, let's see.
What else?
Oh, yes.
I stole a family's room and the cruise.
Forgot that was the one of the main stories you guys want me
to talk about.
So, basically, what the fuck do you mean, Doki?
I just like, I just like, guess who?
The baseball player.
So, uh, what happened was, okay, so it's, it's a reasonable
mistake.
It happens to everybody, including me.
Um, I just happened to accidentally steal a family of four
who has a little child.
Um, gold ocean view, gold plus star ocean view room, which
is apparently a lot more expensive than the room I have.
So, um, all right.
So, it was.
It was an accident.
So I read the numbers wrong.
So, okay, I'm going to randomly say all random numbers.
It's not actually my cruise number.
My cruise room number.
So, um, so it'll be like, okay, it'll be like 844.
So my room number might have technically been 488.
But then I went to 844.
So, you know, like a reasonable mistake.
You know,
so, um, so I, I like got to my, so really, there's never
been to a cruise before.
The keys, they don't give you the keys.
The keys is just on the, um, it's just on the door.
So you just grab the key on the door and everything.
So I assumed I was, I was like, oh, there it is.
844.
That's my room.
844 um so I just grabbed the keys and I went in put all my
stuff away uh and so and then I was just like and uh the
thing is I had a check-in bag so I was they were supposed to
deliver the bag to me and uh um and so when I opened the
door I was just like oh they got I was just like What are
these bags doing in front of my room?
This is not my bag.
Oh, man, they put the wrong bags in front of my room.
They got confused with the numbers.
Whose luggage is this?
Like, these are not my luggage.
You know, that should have been the first sign.
Like, there was a lot of luggage in front of my door.
And I was like, oh, they got my room confused.
They got my room confused.
I was like, oh my god, I need to go speak to the, I need to
go speak to the guest surfaces later to like, see if they
know where my luggage is, because this is not my luggage.
I know, so silly of them.
Anyway, so my room was technically not the ocean view.
It was like the crew.
you know, like the inside of the cruise view, you know, the
shittier view.
So I was just like, oh, that's nice.
I thought I got, I thought I didn't pay for the ocean view.
I must have forgot.
When I got it, I was like, oh, that's nice.
I, I didn't pay for the ocean view.
Oh, I must have did oh I forgot about that so I was like no
that's sweet an ocean view oh that's cool um and then I
opened the room keys I was like oh they gave me four keys
for just me they were so that's like how many more signs can
we send her it's like I was like oh what they gave me four
keys because they're all like by the way the keys i didn't
even look at the cards because like it's my first cruise and
so and it must it's my first cruise so i i didn't realize
the the the cards or whatever is also named by the way miss
jane hill i'm so sorry Today I learned toky birds are killer
fly because that's so many red flags you mix.
Miss Nixie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It was a white family, too, by the way.
Mrs. Jane Hill, I apologize.
Later on, when I found out I got somebody else's room, I
looked at the card and the card literally in big text says,
Miss Jane Hill, like,
so I was like, oh my god, anyway, I didn't notice the name
portion of it.
Anyway, in the envelope with the card keys, I also noticed a
green bracelet, and I was so confused.
I was like, what is this green bracelet?
I don't know what this is.
Like, what is this green bracelet?
um anyway so um after i unpacked everything like and um i
went to get food i remember i think i went to get food and i
asked one of the workers i'd be like hey i got this green
bracelet but i don't know what it's for in my room and
they're like oh that's a child bracelet that uh that you
give to your child so they can access uh the kid friend like
the the children's spots around the cruise so they have
permission to access it I was like oh that's so weird I
guess like I wonder why oh they must have mistaken and gave
it to me I I'm like here by myself I was like why is there
why did they give me that child bracelet so I was just like
oh they must have given this to me by mistake I don't know
why I got I literally here by myself I'm like, why do I have
a child bracelet?
And anyway, I finished eating.
I went back to my room.
My room.
And then my key doesn't work.
I was so confused.
I was just like, oh, what?
And I kept scanning it.
And I used my other, and I got my other card.
And I scanned, you know, not looking at the names of the
card, by the way.
I didn't know.
and then I kept scanning it and I and I was like wait what
what my am I locked out is something wrong and and then one
of the ship staff like the house team staff came I was like
oh we've been looking for you this is not your room and I
was just like what do you mean I'm 844
it's like no you got the wrong room can you look at your
reservation real quick and I looked at it it was like 488
and I was like oh I can see how why that one kid figured out
you're part of the puzzle escape room before they came with
a super chat they can thank you they're like yeah so um the
actual family that um the actual family uh that was uh
supposed to be here um couldn't get in so we had to turn
lock up the whoever owns the keys to make sure to find out
what's going on next thing thank you super chat thank you
thank you how are you able to get into your room in the
first place so the thing is is that for those who don't know
cruises they have the key cards just on the door so they
don't give you the keys they just assume they just like you
just go by your reservation number and then you go to your
door and just get your key from the door and then you go in
like that's that's how it were i don't know why but that's
how it works so so so i just you know i just grabbed the
keys because i thought i was 844 yeah so um so yeah it's
like the honor system basically uh it's the honor system Um,
so anyway, so they're like, yeah, um, the family already,
and I looked at the card after they said, after the guy said
that, I looked at the card, and I saw Miss Jane Hill, and I
saw, I was like, oh, that's why the name is Miss Jane Hill,
that makes so much sense now, I, yeah, I saw the name on the
card, everything, everything clicked right there, so so the
housekeeping guy was like yeah you have to go to guest
services to see to like fix that and i was just like oh but
all my stuff like wait did they move my stuff because all my
stuff was in that room and the housekeeping guy was like no
no no your stuff is here they just we just locked we just
locked the door uh because we just want to figure this out
uh but anyway the new family already was reassigned a new
room so you're welcome by the way i assume they gave them an
upgrade so in in the end you think about it i gave this
family a four a favor because i got them an all expense paid
upgrade i don't know i assume i don't even know i assume
they got an upgrade because they'll be like we're so sorry
for all of this going i assume like they're like in my head
in my imagination the story i came up with to justify what i
just did um to make myself feel better.
This like make-belief story I have in my head is I assume
they got an upgrade.
And they're like, we're so sorry for everything that
happened.
Here's an upgrade or so.
So I did them a favor.
No, the thing is I still had my I went to my actual room and
the keys were still there so I could technically have two
rooms because there was no nobody had I I got the keys from
my actual room and I was like oh shit wait there it is like
there's the shitty view there it is um so anyway so they're
like and I was just like oh like what do i do with that room
with the um that room that accidentally took and they're
like oh you can you it's fine we already reassigned the
family so um that room can be yours now since you already
unpacked everything and but and they're like you just gotta
go to guest services to make the transfer to make sure that
room is fully transferred to your name so it's like in our
files that's all right that's cool so in the end i i i got a
i accidentally got a full up room upgrade with the ocean
side view and it was next to the elevator i think that was
the best part the room was like next to the like not next to
the elevator but it was like very close to the elevator so I
won't have to walk too far because my actual room was in the
middle so it was like a three to four minute walk to get to
either side of the elevator so I was like wow karma's gonna
hit me one day but not that day because that's why i got
sunburned and never punished like so moral of the story is
finders keepers cyber thank you with a super chat thank you
so i end up getting a free upgrade of the ocean side view on
the oh you guys want to see it's pretty nice i'll show you
guys the ocean side view uh next we thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you donkey is a fucking squatter No, I
got accidentally, I caught up, they caught up, kicked me up,
but they didn't, they didn't kick me out, guys, that's on
them, that's, that's on them, not on me, they had a choice
to, instead, they're like, you can keep the room, they let
me keep the room, I mean, Let me see if I can get the photo
of the ocean side view.
Look at that.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, yeah, there it is.
Bum, bada-dum, bada-dum.
I'm trying to get the picture right now.
There it is.
Look at that.
All right.
Now I gotta save this.
Braggapolar ill-gotten games.
All right, here it is guys.
My ocean size view.
That got fair and square.
Very fair and very square.
Let's go.
mine
now that's the ocean the solid day it was legally
transferred over to me so it was no it lost all it's no
longer stolen it was an honest mistake it was
So that's how I accidentally got a family of fours room.
There was a lot of signs, but somehow I missed all of them.
Uh, it was like everyone that he was trying.
Everything was there.
But somehow I just, guys, I was tunnel visioning.
Look at this beautiful ocean I discovered, guys.
Um.
Oh, yeah, by the way, I will say, do not, I don't know,
maybe it depends on the cruises, but, um, cruise
entertainment is, you know, they're like, oh, cruise, maybe
cruise entertainment is, like, hit or miss, it was a huge
miss for me, cruise entertainment was pretty fucking cringe,
it's not great, I don't know, it was so bad, it was, It was,
I, I don't even know how I can describe what I saw.
Like, yeah, like, like, there were like music, there was
like music relax and like, um, and like performances and,
it's like, I would give it a one.
It was so bad.
I, I, I took a video of one of, it was so funny.
Like, like, okay, there were some, there was a part there
that wasn't supposed to laugh at, but it was so fucking bad.
I don't know if I was the only one that lap it was so the
music was so loud so people don't hear me I literally went
Ha I was like I saw it I'm like good but I think it was OCD
and serious so it was like a superhero thing a superhero
parody or whatever the fuck it was um and a guy came out
like I don't know his name is I don't even know his name he
was like some fucking lizard man costumes where where you're
on a t-rex where you're riding like a horse or a t-rex or
whatever you know what I'm talking about like these types of
oh my god like these type of costumes all right so so the
guy came out I'm wearing this like not exactly like this it
was more customized but like He was came out wearing this
and I literally went,
That's so fucking stupid.
Stand-up comedy was good.
I went to the stand-up comedy show and that was the only
good, like, entertainment on the cruise.
And, um, so, yeah, yeah.
But the thing is, the guy was also dressed up as a lizard
man so it was like a lizard man on a lizard so it was like
pretty i i thought it was fucking hilarious like the imagery
of all that shit and um but like it was obviously supposed
to be super serious because it was like a musical like
performance or whatever um so it was like a lizard man on a
lizard and i thought i was so fucking stupid and funny and i
took a video of it But I don't think I can I don't I feel
bad showing it was so cringe, but I'm like they're trying
the performers are trying their best But it was so fucking
cringe So basically I'll give like the story of this musical
and Um, and it was basically like They're like there's a
superhero.
I don't know.
It's like a sequel apparently from the first one.
I don't know think it matters it was like very they were
doing cover songs by the way it's not like original music
they were doing like they were just covering established
songs and stuff like it was just cover music so i don't i
can't on top of my head i can't name the songs that they
were singing but anyway so the story was um two villains
there were two big bad villains and they were kidnapping
superheroes one by one like these original superheroes that
they made up and then so but didn't kidnap the last guy and
he was gonna be like i will save them all i'm gonna save
everybody and the ending was so fucking stupid um because
like each there was a musical performance for each superhero
that that like they would introduce the superhero they had
their own original song like not original they had their own
like like music performance and everything and the villain
comes in and like they do their own like musical performance
and everything and then they the superhero and then that was
it that was like each scene and then they failed to kidnap
the last superhero so then the superhero was supposed to
come and rescue the rest of the other heroes and then it was
not made for this was musical was technically not for kids
not like because it was like at 11 p.m so i was like they're
not bringing a child to this musical like so and then the
hero the villain was like then the villains had their big
bad musical numbers with drones by the way which was sick i
thought a drone part was really cool uh by the way there was
like there was like um some people next to me that were
falling asleep by the way i looked over and they were asleep
um understandable because it was like pretty i was like i'm
here i'm gonna see it to the end type deal you know i was
like i might i'm i fuck yeah i'm here i might as well see it
to the end so there was a drone show in the middle of
there's like the bad evil bad guys musical performance and
then the superhero comes in and then There was like, um, so
there was like a platform there with a button, and then
literally it was like a five, I swear to God, this was a
three minute segment.
This was three minutes, they spent 90% of the musical
kidnapping all these superheroes, and then for the ending,
the one hero they couldn't kidnap comes in, the villain was
like, don't press that button, and then the hero presses the
button and saves the day.
end and i was just like oh that build up just for the guy to
press the button and then all the heroes were freed and the
wind like the guy was like don't press that button he
presses it bam the end And everybody's, like, our heroes are
like, we did it!
We're all free now!
And then the villains get insta-arrested?
And, like, what?
Like, like, like, I'm just, it was just that easy,
apparently.
But it was, like, a one-hour-plus musical.
I think one hour and 30 minutes or some shit, I don't
fucking know.
It's, like, a 90-minute show.
And then, oh, fucking, It ties it all up in five minutes, I
guess.
It's like, you're free now.
So I did take a video of, like, bits and parts of them.
But I won't show it because I don't, I feel bad.
I, like, this is like a point where I felt bad trying to
show this.
Like, yeah.
So, yeah, so.
But I did watch, okay, so there was, there were some fun
entertainment, but that's because it included, like, the
cruise guests.
Those were the ones that weren't cringe.
So I went to, like, the 18-plus game shows, because that's
when shit gets wild, you know, like, you know, the children
aren't here and now.
So I went to one called Girls vs.
Boys, and I was like, oh, that's interesting, you know,
like, oh, what is this?
Girls vs.
Boys shit.
team of girls and team of boys to like compete against each
other and like it was so funny and i wish i didn't come in
there in the middle of the show i because i was just i was a
little late i don't remember what i was doing but i was a
little late um and um fucking no i did not join it was like
it was wild so like um so okay so there was one the gender
wars so the girls won spoiler there the girls won because
like the girls okay because there was a game where the guys
were like no homo but anyway I came in the middle of it so
there was one where they're doing skits and so I don't know
one I guess it was giving birth or some shit and then each
of the girls were playing I didn't see the guys skit but I
saw the girls skit and um each of the girls had to play a
role about like giving like they're doing RP or some shit I
came in the middle of it and it was like And then they were
like trying to, like the host was like, oh, what role are
you playing?
He's like, oh, I'm the mom.
I'm the mom.
I'm the baby.
I'm the doctor.
And then one of the girls that was sitting in the audience
was like, you forgot about me.
And then she was like, oh, I didn't know you were part.
I forgot you were part of this role play.
What are you?
And because she was on her phone just like sitting there in
the audience.
And she's like, I'm the dad playing 2K while my wife was
giving birth.
I was just like, yeah, I don't know, I thought that was, I
was like, that's so clever, bro.
You should go to cop, you should do improv.
I was like, I was like, girl, you should do improv, that's
clever, that's surreal, yeah, fair enough.
Bro, 200 IQ.
I was just like, damn, you're good, girl.
You're fucking good.
Wait, but 2K is fun.
Okay, anyway, so the reason why Bro brought his Xbox to
delivery room.
Okay, so the reason why the girls won was because the last
game was they have to pop the balloon.
So, they're like, that's not too bad.
When they popped the balloon, the guys were like, no homo.
It's so obvious the girls were like, fuck yeah, let's do
this.
Y'all's got a little uncomfortable.
Oh, I see where this is.
Cowards.
Weak.
Okay, it was so funny because one of the guys' wife actually
was like, uh-uh, no-uh, girl, no-uh, because, like, she
thought it was, like, the girls and the guys were, the girls
were gonna pop the balloons with the guys, so one of the
guys' wife, actually, was, like, wanted to stop the whole
thing, was, like, no-uh, girl, no-uh, not my man, and, and,
and then, I was like, no, no, it's fine, it's just guys with
guys, girls with girls and she's like oh all right that's
fine like it's so funny and it's like it's okay it's guys
with guys don't worry don't worry ma'am it's guys with guys
and girls with girls like yeah i gotta see the trap and he's
like i'll get in the coast i'll give you examples so then
she he gave the wife the balloon and he's like all right you
got and then told the guy all right to the to the husband it
was like turn around and face like stick your butt out stick
your ass out and put your hands on the bar and then i and
then he told the wife i was like all right you know what to
do and she like was like thrusting the balloon behind him
and to pop the balloon and it's like all right yeah so
that's what and he's like this is the example we're gonna do
but it would be god yeah the wife was so into it by the way
the wife was like it was so into it like yeah see that's why
it was 18 plus so i was like that was like the most fun one
i watched so um yeah it was freaky as fuck so anyway so um
so each team uh what had a captain they had to nominate a
captain so they were the main the main guy that was main guy
or girl that's gonna be part of all the balloon popping so
so the guy you know one of them he has to turn around the
other one he has to you know hip to hip and then i think the
funniest one was where The captain has to lie down And then
the other guy has to grab the balloon And then sit on the
guy's crotch To pop it
So you tell why the guys lost this round You can sort of...
Okay, I see why they lost They did what the fuck.
So, yes, girls, fucking breeze right through it.
Like, definitely no home.
No, the guys made an effort.
The guys, honestly, one of the reason why they lost was
because one of the balloons just didn't pop.
So they kept having to do it over and over again until they
popped.
Damn, anything goes.
Like, they did it.
They did all of it.
It was just unlucky.
because the balloon didn't pop so they kept having it they
kept trying to do it
so we gotta see all the poses from the boys and the girls
side but it was just the girls were faster because the
balloons actually popped the guys unfortunately did not pop
like there was like one or two balloons that just did not
pop and they were trying so hard to make it pop like bro
throw a cider bro bro put your back into it bro no homo no
homo by the way
yeah yeah so so it was fucking wild i thought it was fucking
hilarious like
game or their game was just weak
yeah yeah so check the balloon read this ring check the
balloons bro you're checking the balloons yeah now yeah that
was entertainment yeah so that was my favorite part of the
entertainment of the entertainment on the cruise I didn't
know it was very fun but only because the people they
selected was really funny like and the games there was
pretty fucking hilarious all right anyway so so I like I
said I did go to a I did go to a to a themed restaurant and
it was like Alice in Wonderland theme so it was pretty it
was pretty you know like those like experimental Michelin
star restaurants where like things are deconstructed or like
they use like like there was one where they used like one of
the meals they used like beakers or some shit like that type
of crazy food dining experience I had for free technically
um and uh and it was so okay so let me see what i don't
think i took a picture of it so yeah yeah so it's like you
know abstract food yes it was like abstract food and let me
see if i took any pictures of the crazy shit i had all right
so so like it was wild so the menu they gave you like it was
like invisible ink type menu where it reveals itself and you
paint on the menu with water it's like that type of fancy
crazy abstract shit that they do so I went there because
like it was sort of it was free technically and like for it
was like paid for it by like the art gallery so I was just
like fuck it let's try it so like they reserved it for me
and stuff and everything so I was just like so it was like
an experience and so So, and, like, the food was like, okay,
this is so funny.
So, I gave, I do, like, did, like, the chef's
recommendation.
So, they just bring out, like, the things that were, like,
the most popular.
And then, like, for appetizers.
And then the main course was, oh, yeah, there was a
deconstructed tomato.
Let me show you guys this.
It was, like, a deconstructed, okay, so there was one that
was, like, a deconstructed tomato.
uh let me see there's i didn't make sure there's no
reflections or anything it was weird it was uh that one so
like but we pick uh like i get to pick the um main course so
so it was weird it was funny because i wanted risotto i saw
risotto but i didn't realize it was a Reconstructed risotto.
I did take a picture of it because I was like, I'm...
And then the waiter was warning me and was like, are you
sure it's very small?
You might want...
Oh, that's core of my kamioshi.
Mr. McFluff, again, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
They're like, are you sure?
It's...
I didn't...
Okay, when it said deconstructed, I didn't realize that's...
Okay, so you guys will be like, what are you talking about,
Doki?
I was like, when you, let me say I could find a picture of
it, because I didn't take a picture of it, because I just,
it was that, I was like, it was like two spoons.
And they warned me too.
They were like, are you sure?
It's, it's, it's very, very tiny.
I recommend you to order something else.
And I was just like, oh, but I really want a risotto.
I didn't really want a deconstructed risotto, even though it
was on the menu labeled deconstructed risotto.
Like, so this was a constructed tomato so I you see the like
it's weird it's weird it was everything was just it was good
but it was weird the fuck it's a deconstructed tomato that's
like that's a deconstructed tomato guys it's like like I was
like what did they do to the tomato like what the fuck did
they do it
that's the tomato like the it was sweet it was so it was
like a weird i don't even know how to describe the taste
like you're just imagine doing this to you tomorrow probably
next see thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
okay let me see if i can find it okay wonder i'm gonna try
and google this uh i need to show you guys the deconstructed
I know.
Wait, is this it?
Is this a deconstructed risotto?
We need to see if I could find it because it was so, I did
not realize that it was a deconstructed risotto.
Like, that's, that's one of the, what got me.
That's what, that's how, what they got me with, because I
was just like, Oh, I really want risotto.
And I didn't realize that that was the risotto.
I think it is this.
Let me check.
It was like a truffle risotto or some shit.
And I was just like, ooh, it looks good.
And there was a truffle mushroom risotto.
Okay.
So.
So I'm going to show you what this looks like.
And you're going to be like, that can't be.
yet oh but it is
all right so i was like can't wait for my main dish guys i'm
so excited i i'm so excited for my main dish
this was the tea This is a deconstructed
Where is the food?
It was just a solid spoon
I thought it was So I didn't see the deconstructed part No,
it was not one spoon It was technically two They gave me two
spoons They gave me two instead of one.
Just the main course.
Is that the music?
Guys, it's artistic.
Guys, a spoonful of sugar makes the medicine go down.
The medicine go down.
I got two spoons.
So, yeah.
You guys, can you see the rice?
So there's the rice on top and the mushrooms on the side and
the truffle in the bottom.
Just take the plate away, Jesus.
But guys, it's so artistic, guys.
It's abstract art.
That's rice.
so it was literally a spoon you you might be thinking oh
that must have been a really big spoon right perspective
that's just them playing with persp it was the size of a
spoon it was the size of a spoon a normal size spoon by the
way i i'm sorry simon thank you miss richard thank you thank
you i now see why hardness are starving if this is what
they're creating but But I will say their dessert is like
where it's at their dessert is where it's at though I had
them I saw someone got okay, so I got there these were the
what the desserts look like The desserts was what they sold
with I feel like in like the fancy restaurant the dessert is
It's where they go crazy on um So this is because it's Alice
themed right so like I'll show you it's actually really cool
I didn't get this one.
I saw someone else get it.
I was like, oh, I should have got that.
But like, I couldn't, obviously, I couldn't order one
dessert.
Like, I'm cooking.
I'm ready.
Technically, I'm ready for.
They gave me more than that.
By the way, it was like a lot of mini appetizers.
And then I was like, oh boy, I can't wait for the main dish.
I'm starting to get full.
But anyway, this was like one of the desserts they had.
I didn't know what it was.
I got the other one where it was like, I don't remember what
it's called.
It was like the globe or whatever.
Um, uh yeah it was really so i got i got where is it i got
this um where they it was like a globe and they poured uh
they like poured like uh caramel on top uh not deconstructed
where's my deconstruction of a of a dessert you know
so i got this instead because i saw someone else get it and
i was like oh that looks yeah where is this food i saw that
i got this one um were they basically i didn't take a
picture of it but or video but um it's kind of remember what
it's called it was like the globe or some and inside was
like moose and chocolate whatever like a cake or something
so it would melt the sphere and then inside was like a moose
slash cake and it was so it was actually my favorite dessert
um like it was my favorite dessert of the entire cruise uh
during the vacation so that was good that was really good
other than like it made up for a deconstructed risotto it
was this this made it was it was honestly like my favorite
dessert out of like the entire vacation it made up for this,
whatever.
My king died little rice creams and all that.
It's made up for that.
Yeah.
I should maybe heed my waiter's warnings when they were
like, are you sure you want this resort?
Are you sure?
It's very small.
Maybe you should order another main dish said but I was like
no I just don't want to eat too I was just like it's okay I
don't want to eat too they could have told me it was served
on the fucking spoon and they told if the waiter told me it
was on a fucking tidy ass spoon I thought you know I thought
it would be I didn't think it was that small like also the
fact that it was a deconstructed risotto I like it was yeah
you you know when i think small i just be like oh it's just
a tiny plate not on a fucking spoon like one spoon sorry two
spoonfuls like it was i will i know it's so it wasn't guys i
i it's oh man i it's it's really crazy to believe it guys i
know it's gonna be so hard to good I I know it's crazy to
believe this but but the deconstructed risotto did not even
taste good I say it ate soap but it looks so appetizing no
way the shocker is Imagine my shock to find out that it
tastes like ass.
I don't...
Guys, I didn't look at the prices, guys.
It was free, technically.
I painted by an art.
Yeah.
Yeah, it was...
Oh, yeah.
Also, okay.
Other than that, oh yeah.
By the way, they felt so sorry for me they gave me fried mac
and cheese like the meal that they give to the kids um you
know i'll take it they're like oh just because like uh we
felt like you should like maybe uh you're still hungry
here's some fried mac and cheese like the ones that they
serve to the children like it was for free i mean it was
originally for free anyway yeah like it was like i noticed
they gave these to the kid it was my pity mac and cheese
because uh the kids got like there was table next to me with
the kids and the kids got it uh so i got it too um um oh
yeah by the way so i did go to the stand-up comedy show and
when i said there was some rich ass people on the ship um i
was going to the comedy show and the guy was you know um i
was warned when i went in i think like i don't remember who
warned me i don't remember it was the art gallery people or
the um or like some the staff there that was like oh yeah
the comedy show is good don't sit in the front because the
comedian will pick you because like it's like those type of
comedians those types of stand-up comics where they use the
audience to do their bits and stuff to you know how like you
know i like riff off of you guys oh you dragons they do that
so yeah they do crowd work so they're like don't sit in the
front or the guy will pick you um to like riff off of you
and i was like i don't want to talk
I don't want to do I don't want to be part of the crowd work
and shit.
Yeah, I don't get roasted.
I already
I'm on vacation I get roasted enough like I'm a content
creator don't I like I don't need to get roasted online and
in real life like So So he does crowd work and then like he
was like talking to like a guy this group of this family who
has like a bunch of kids kids I guess they're like 18 plus
because it was an 18 plus show and he was talking to them
and they were like oh yeah like they are all staying the
giant sweets at the top of the cruise so you know they're
rich rich because like it was like you know five or six
teenagers and like like a mom and dad in the back so like
the five 16 years were like group of friends they're not
related or anything um and then like you know the mom and
dad they're like they're like oh what does your dad know the
comedian was like wait you guys are on the top of the cruise
you're all seeing that same the sweet room and you're like
yeah we're seeing the sweet room there he was talking to the
teenagers and they're like 18 plus so they're like about to
head to college or whatever you know you know vacation
before university uh first year university and the the kid
was like yeah this is my dad he manages money you know he's
like yeah that's my dad he manages money and uh and you know
as an embezzlement like i was like oh yeah He definitely
manages money.
Where's his offshore bank accounts?
That's not, like, we didn't say that, but in my, see, I can
do this too, guys.
It's so easy.
Crowell works so easy.
I can be like, oh yeah, like with his offshore, where's his
offshore bank accounts, guys?
Like, yeah.
Yeah, oh yeah.
Maybe like, like, you know, take some off the top, you know?
Like, the managing money.
Yeah.
Anyway, anyway, so then he asked the other kid, like, oh,
what do you want to, what are you studying to be doing for?
He's like, oh, criminal justice, I'm, you know, he's like,
criminal justice, and he's like, and then he didn't stop
there.
I was like, oh, shit, this kid is, you know, wanting to,
like, go into law, or, like, I don't know, forensics or
something.
He's like, I'm studying to be an FBI agent, and I'm like,
damn, that's so complicated.
And this kid was like, yeah, I'm criminal justice.
I'm studying to be an FBI agent.
And I'm like, damn, what?
Like to put his dad, like put his friend's dad in jail, by
the way.
Like, yeah, well, kids got dreams.
Yeah.
I respect that goal.
Yeah, I was like, holy shit.
Shit.
Oh my God.
And the other kids were like, the dad's kid was also
planning on managing money too.
He was like, I'm going to, uh, econ slash business to follow
in my dad's footsteps.
And it was like, econ, accountant, like, you know, money,
you know, rich kid stuff.
Like Jakarta, thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
You had enough roasting from dragoons.
So you're good, Doki.
Also hope you had a really good vacation.
Enjoy the free time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You know, you got, you know, the dad's sons got to have an
inside man with the government, you know.
Out there it's all connected.
Of course his best friend, the dad who's managing money, his
son who's also looking into managing money, his best friend
is studying to become an FBI agent.
Hmm.
Gotta have an inside man, So they can continue to manage
money very legally.
Hmm.
but it all makes sense now
um so I thought I was like the future politician I thought
uh the side plot of an HBO special or some shit yeah I
thought that that was like really fun to go to it was really
good really fun comedian well it was too they had an opener
in the main main like swap between because i went to two of
the um stand-up comic shows because they were the most
interesting one the most fun one to go to out of all the
stuff entertainment on the christian when you're like
trapped in the fucking boat in the middle of the ocean
there's like only like little things you can i did a fucking
escape room guys i paid ten dollars to do the the most ass
escape room i've ever it was like my ass i meant it was
majority of the problems was just math and i was just like
cat i had a kid use chat gpt to like um to to fucking try to
solve the questions and stuff like we did not escape the
room by the way he did not escape the room we were still
trapped there to this day uh um anyway so um what did i say
uh i did bingo i did bingo um i paid 30 for bingo i did not
realize how fucking lucrative the bingo uh the the bingo
business is i got a bingo marker too and everything and
they're like you don't want to spend 80 more to buy 60 more
bingo sheets and i was like i'm fine i'm i'll take the one
bingo sheet please because apparently they do this thing now
where they to um so you have more of a chance to win uh you
can have digital bingo sheets where they give you an ipad
with an app by the way they don't even roll the balls
anymore it's all on the app we live in a time where bingo is
just done on an app now um there's not even the balls
anymore they just they just press a button on the bingo app
and yeah yeah yeah so um so they press they press a button
on the bingo app and then the clicking powerpoint not
powerpoint like you know like the uh the screen shows the
app itself tells you the number and everything then the
letter and shit like uh yeah and the bingo sheets stamped
themselves so they're like you don't have to worry about
stamping it it because it's linked up to the cloud or
whatever the fuck it's synced up so like to the app so
people it just automatically stamps it for you you don't
have to do anything anyway it was my first time doing bingo
i was like it's all right i don't need to pay 80 i don't
need to pay 110 american dollars for 60 more for the ipad
bingo sheets like
Thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Imagine the future, Tokyo, cat and mouse game of the FBI
agent and the criminal child and friend, friends to enemies,
and maybe even lovers.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Well, the kid with the dad that manages money has a
girlfriend, so I don't, unless that's a beard, so I don't
know if that's going to happen.
No, I think I know too much about this family.
That guy really did a lot of crowd work on them.
um i i know too much information about this random rich
family that's sad in the front um live thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you roblox bingo with dragon ones
when thank you super chat think you think oh yeah bro there
was like a fucking newly like be like i don't know like
bachelor party like and then um um so you know she was on
the cruise with her girlies and stuff she was at the comic
show too and the guy and then she was she was like I'm
getting married and then the guy was like the comedian was
like oh where's the husband and she's like at home it's my
day and then the comedian was like uh it was just like you
just left your fiance at home
I was just like, why?
I was just why he just left him at home.
It's like, at least like bring him to the, I don't know.
I feel like that's weird.
Like, I guess, because it's a bachelorette party too, but
then he just left him at home.
The poor, she was drunk.
She was drunk as hell.
Like, he hasn't the time of his life.
The thing is, the comedian the comic was like oh um where's
where's your husband or where's your fiance and then she
didn't she didn't say at home at first she was like it's my
day you know like and then he was just like ma'am I asked
about your fiance like I know I just want to know where he
is like yeah And she was like, it's my day!
And she's like, and then he was like, ma'am, I was just
asking where your fiance is.
I know it's your day.
I know you're getting married as your bachelor, but where is
he?
He's like, he's at home.
She didn't care where he was.
Yeah, she did not care.
Like, yeah.
Bro, she was drunk as hell.
I don't think she even knows where she was.
Yeah.
I hope the marriage is better than what I just saw.
Like, um, anyway.
Okay, where was I?
Oh, yeah, so I didn't get a bingo.
Oh, yeah, I took a picture of it.
I posted it on Twitter.
No bingo from me.
Not even close.
Not even fucking close.
Uh, but yeah, I didn't buy the fucking...
iPad for the digital bingo shit.
Um, I was just like, fuck, it's my first time doing bingo.
I don't, it's fine.
I did not care that much.
I just wanted to experience it, you know?
Um, so here's my little bingo sheet.
$30, by the way.
For three pieces of paper.
Cause it's like one, yeah, so like I that they for the
hardcore bingo goers if you want to pay a hundred and ten
dollars you get an ipad with 60 plus sheets uh mine was
three it's very thin by the way um with the marker uh
without the marker by the way the marker was an extra ten
dollars because i unfortunately i'm not professional bingo
player so i didn't bring my own marker so i had to i had to
use my own i had to buy my own bingo marker uh
So, um, um, so, yeah, honestly, it's fine.
I got my first bingo, $30 for three bingo sheets because
it's a default.
They do three games.
So it's weird.
It's not all bingo.
It's not just like bingo, bingo, where it's aligned.
It's like aligned four corners.
So it's like three different games.
I did not realize.
It's like four corners, align, and then equal sign.
Each paper is its own kind of bingo game.
So, I didn't win any of them.
I think it's because of the curse of the 6-7.
And the 69.
I think I have both 69 and 6-7 on my sheet.
We're not winning that.
So, um, so that's bingo.
Anyway, so, I...
I got to know about the art gallery people slash auctioneer
people and I gotta know more about cruise life because I
thought it was really interesting.
Like I said, it's my first time cruising.
So it was very interesting to like learn about cruise life.
So they were telling me about like they're like telling me
like cruise contracts and everything and like how long
they've been working.
There was two of the staff met each other on the cruise and
they were actually married and everything else like oh
that's cute um like there's like a married couple that like
two of the staff members were a married couple that met from
doing this from doing cruises and i thought that was really
really cute and everything you're telling me um they're all
from around the world one was from belarus i don't know
belarus uh uh south africa um germany like like the thing i
found interesting is like people on the cruise are from
around the world so they're not like they're like not like
like they recruit people from around the world and
everything so it was really interesting and I was like uh
the main auctioneer the main head manager of the art gallery
slash auctioneer um he was uh you know I was talking to all
of them and he was telling me how like he used to be uh uh
he used to be a rugby player like a professional rugby
player and a professional tennis player and apparently uh
but like he was like in like the like south africa
professional rugby team and everything and i thought that
was really fucking cool and i was like learning more about
like each people like each of them you know i wanted to
learn more about their lives and everything and learn more
about the cruise life and everything because i like i like
listening to people's life stories because everyone has
their own story and everything and then okay all right but
basically he had knee injury he had a knee injury so and he
apparently like one of his mates you know sorry you know you
know you know i got like an influence from the south africa
lingo or one of his mates that he used to like 1v1 spar with
in tennis end up going to wimbledon and he was like oh man
if i never had because they have to pick between tennis or
professional rugby he had a pick between tennis and
professional rugby and then he picked professional rugby
because he enjoyed the sport more but then he was saying he
wished he stuck with tennis because one of his mates that he
would do 1v1 like you know scrim spar with in tennis ended
up going to wimbledon and he was like oh like i was like
around like i was around his level and he's like oh i could
have went to wimbledon if i stuck with tennis and he was
like oh but i just enjoy rugby more and then he was like you
know he was like a partier so he would go to like the cruise
parties and everything and um um and then he i was telling
oh yeah like because you know like i learned about the other
two staff there was married and i asked him i was like are
you single like are you married are you single blah blah
like what's going on with your life you know like what's
going on with why are you single like yeah why why aren't
you dating like no i meant like what's going on with your
life and he's like oh i'm talking to um i'm talking to like
this ice skate no i was i talked to the ice skater um who
was performing there and i and i was just like oh that's
interesting i was like oh that's cute and i was saying uh no
okay no this is hilarious so and okay okay you know i was
like eugenics i don't want to always bring back the eugenics
But he was like, I have a plan.
He's like, I have a plan.
I know what my son's gonna be.
This is for everyone.
So I was like, oh, like Holland, you know, I was just like,
you know, because I talked about world.
I was also like with the, I think I just hanged.
out with like the art guy slash auctioneer people and just
like had a like talked with all of them like in a group and
it was just like it's like like holland so so so we were
talking about world cup earlier too because like majority of
people at the auctioneer place was like south africa slash
european so you know they love world cup they love soccer
and everything and so i was joking around being like oh shit
like holland you know because we were talking about world
cup dad and mom were literally like, like they made the
perfect soccer child, you know, like football, but the
perfect child for football, except he's not very good at
endurance.
We will say his stamina is not quite high, but other than
that, almost the perfect child for football.
So, so he's like, yeah, I'm looking for a girl, like, I'm,
I'm trying, I'm looking for someone Who's athletic and he is
like yeah, so I want my I'm gonna make sure my kid becomes a
professional rugby player He's he's trying to he's like
already looking into the future.
He's like yeah, I want to make sure he becomes a
professional rugby player So I'm looking for I'm looking for
someone athletic and so I've been talking to like the girl
the Nice from the ice skating Cruise like he says he has a
plan He has a plan guys like I was just like I was just like
damn And then I'll figure it out I guess That's That's your
deadlift Yeah I was like what if he wants I was like what if
he wants to play Like baseball or something oh wait no I was
like what if he wants to play soccer and he's like bro he's
less like I okay I'm trying to remember what he said exactly
but like this is verbatim he doesn't want his son to be a
pussy because he doesn't want him to like like he's like I
ain't raising I'm not raising a kid that's gonna fucking
fake an injury on the ground yeah yeah I don't remember what
he said You don't want your son to be a pussy
I said that but um But I don't remember Yeah he ain't
raising a flopper He doesn't want him to be flopping On the
field and everything So he's like I'm not raising a kid to
play football Like
Yeah Yeah So So, I only, I like football, but I meant like,
I attributed, um, the, the pussy part with the flopping, you
know, the acting part.
So, so he's like, so he's like, he's gonna be playing rugby,
or, and I was like, okay, but then, then I was like, what
about baseball?
And he's like, well, if I move to America, maybe baseball is
fine, or maybe American football.
He's like, I was like, what, he's like, oh, nah, I'll be
like, it was like, I moved to America, then maybe American
football, but like, he's like, my plan is rugby.
Next, see, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, I thought it was going somewhere else, but he's got a
point.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I know, that's so fucking funny.
He's like, he's like, he's not going to be flopping on those
fields if I have anything to say about it.
Like,
yeah yeah i'm just like damn it's like rugby or american
football
jacquardo thank you super chat thank you thank you this is
like sound like trying to maximize what stats the kids get
and fire them depending on what pairs you make but instead
it's irl sport and my song ain't gonna be a fucking floppy
like thank you super chat thank you thank you and his son
becomes a figure skater you know
it's like perfect the perfect physique
oh that was really funny
what would the kid i'm curious i'm curious where the kids
gonna go guys
dude was passionate about his hypothetical chat he has a
plan guys he has a plan mexico thank you super chat thank
you thank you the kid's gonna be in art in 20 years all
right so from this conversation i found out about the
swingers cruise because like i said i was I wanted to know
like what are the best cruises if I want to do more of them
in the future like not more of them But if I want to do
another one.
I'm not gonna be a cruise person guys I it was like a maybe
like once every like maybe like a couple of years thing not
like a fucking regular cruise person so So if you guys
didn't watch the twitch stream or mint slash Nimi's streams
where I talked about it i wanted to be like oh so like what
are the best cruises to do like most expensive fancy cruises
or like just like overall best because they worked on a lot
of cruises so i was like because they don't they're not like
specific specific in one cruise they do a lot of different
cruises in general so they obviously don't know no more
about which is the best so they were talking about i don't
remember what it's called i don't i should have wrote this
down but i know about the swingers cruise like
even okay i learned about the pineapple during this
conversation i did not realize i you know i don't know
anything about the culture obviously so so okay i didn't
know anything about it so um for those who don't know the
pineapple is the symbol of swinging of swingers so if
someone is so now okay i'm gonna open your minds i also
learned learn about this in the stand-up comedy because they
So for those who don't know, if you see, if you're on a
cruise or anything, or like honestly, like an event or
something, and if they wear anything related to a pineapple,
like a Hawaiian shirt that's just filled with pineapples,
they're swingers, because that's the international symbol of
swinging.
And if the pineapple, if you're, okay, so for those who
don't know, on cruises, the doors are metal, so people would
like to decorate their doors.
and stuff um so they would decorate their doors and then
some people who want them others to know that they're
swingers they would get like pineapple magnets and then they
would flip it upside down to signify to other swingers that
they are also swingers so like the store is where they live
this is their room anyway and also they would wear pineapple
hawaiian shirts it's so so it's like there it's like the bat
signal you know it's like the swinger signal to the world
they're like you know what i'm doing today like the swinger
code like yeah um and then so depending at the back signal
and it's the hoshi mark yeah so so they were telling me the
auctioneer people were telling me about how yeah um um this
the best cruise is this cruise um but it's like 50 usually
because it's like the rich and fancy cruises are usually uh
vacated by like the like the old and the old rich people
because you know they're either retire they can afford it
because they are retired or you know they're they're you
know they're not they're like rich old retired people that
can afford these types of cruises so they're usually like 50
plus year old um um you know middle age you know people
adults on those crews there's no like young people there
because usually the young people are working or don't have
enough money to afford these types cruises so n7 thank you
super chat thank you thank you welcome back dokey do the dog
shirts have pineapples unfortunately it's hot dogs um thank
you super chat thank you thank you thank you forward thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you so um so i made a
joke being like oh uh oh so is there like a lot of swingers
there you know like it's a he he ha ha moment is the cruise
just full of swingers then because they're like 50 plus year
old year old like middle age men and women like looking for
excitement or whatever you know like that's a joke and then
they're like oh there's a cruise for that and that was like
what can they they were like there's a cruise for that and
I'm like what do you what is that I always said that's like
what do you what do you mean by that so mint searched it up
on her powerworld stream I did not because I was just
telling it she actually looked it up because I okay I
remember the name of that cruise because it's like burn into
my mind when they're explaining it to me so it's called the
bliss cruise and they say yeah that's gonna be in november
um no i know about the gay cruise one of the auctioneers
were talking telling me about the house about the gay
cruises and stuff but all right so it's called the bliss
cruise and it's November the next one's in November by the
way and apparently some of them is already sold out by the
way there the oh yeah by the way the one in November already
sold out holy shit it's already sold out oh my god okay um
it's 100 percent sold out already so um so i learned a lot
about the bliss cruise so basically okay this is gonna be
wild i'm gonna say yeah this is gonna be a wild explanation
this is gonna be a wild explanation because i i was like
when i was listening listening to this I was like the entire
time so um the head manager slash uh auctioneer is gonna be
working on that cruise in November uh so that's why he was
like so he was like he was debating of whether or not to
take the job.
He was debating whether or not to take it, but he was like,
I think he was like, I think I'm going to take it because I
want to know what it's like.
Because he was like telling us, he was telling us, like me
and like the other auctioneer people, because they were
like, they were like, this is the first time I've heard
about this part.
They were like, um, his like mates were like, you gotta try
this at least once because it's crazy.
But basically, they're everybody's naked or mostly naked.
so like like a closer optional like I think that's what mint
read apparently through that it said apparently on the
website it was like closer optional or some shit I look at I
was like oh closer optional damn I don't remember the exact
it's apparently in the fine print um And he was saying how
when he does like his mates that did the auction stuff on
those cruises Um, basically they would come to the auction
auction house Naked and then they'll be doing like, you
know, do I have a 30?
Do I have 30?
Do I have 40?
40 for you So all those they were they were raising the
placards and everything Naked I'm so he's like I was like, I
feel like I should experience that at least once just to see
how that's like so yeah so um so basically what i was
described to me about this cruise was that was that they
would convert they would come you know how there's stores
and restaurants and stuff i'm like trying to describe what
after fucking Okay, that's freaking freaky as hell.
I like the cafe.
This is a real cruise.
This is a real cruise But Basically Um Oh my goodness, this
is a real fucking cruise So all the stores and restaurants
are converted They're converted to PTSM dungeon
That was just like What?
It's like, yeah So, three of the stories...
Okay.
What?
So, if you're anybody's relatives, parents, friends are
going to the Wonderland cruise on November.
They're in for a fucking treat.
Yeah.
Yeah, so, yeah.
I'll be like, Bro, what?
They're just...
Do you want me to...
Yeah, in those...
In the dungeons.
And...
I must have matured.
Excuse me, can you say that again?
You did not...
I will say you did not mishear me.
If you're like, that can't be real.
It is real.
You could go on a website yourself and read it.
I did not go on a website, but read it out loud to all of
us.
Like, to me and Nimi.
um yeah so that's that's the that's the the swingers cruise
that's the swingers cruise um but yeah i didn't i've learned
something new that day i
I've learned something new that day Um Anyway I guess that
was my cruise life That was my Bahamas cruise adventure
Recap last topic I was making Robin Darius thank you for the
super chat Thank you thank you Google bliss bliss cruise I
think you might want to search up bliss cruise it explains
it better than me did you learn what was the best cruise I
did I just forgot the name of it it's like but it's it's
like it's just a fancy ass old person cruise because like
they're usually the only ones that can afford it I mean no
kids at least I chose the wrong the worst time to go on a
cruise because there are so many kids.
Because it was like the end of, you know, it was like the
end of summer vacation.
So like all the parents were bringing the kids to the cruise
because they were like, it's the end of summer vacation.
So just too many.
But that's just my issue.
It was just, there was just not a lot.
There was not, it's not like everybody was a child.
It's just, you know, a bit too many kids for my liking.
don't know it's just basically it yeah i'm trying to think
of what other stuff i could if i forgot anything else it was
just so relaxing though i felt very motivated coming back um
i just felt like very like oh i i actually want to work on
stuff you know coming back because i really needed that
vacation i needed that reset i had a really good time but i
do miss streaming i really and I miss my okay I honestly
though the PC I was using was pretty good like I legit I was
like I never got 200 plus frames streaming rivals before
streaming like FPS games so I don't know what the fuck is
around with my PC but like if I had the sound system that I
have here on my setup and I took my friend's PC it would
have been the perfect match it was it was fiber internet It
turned out there was 500, so that was good.
Yeah, Rivals and Apex were smooth as hell.
Like, I need that.
I thought I had, I don't know, my specs are crazy.
I thought I had better specs, but I don't know.
I do.
I think my PC is just not optimized.
Oh, on a cruise?
Pretty...
Alright.
It was just okay.
I want to say, like, obviously it's like internet in the
middle of the fucking ocean so it's not like obviously it's
not like fiber but at least it was i i could use my phone
and stuff also i need to use the bathroom i'll bring it back
guys i'm back guys you give the homie a kiss and tuck them
in good night uh factor space hey stuff zecra j and nexi tv
bite nepper cyber W Island, Fowler, Solid.
Thank you, Mr. Pritchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, yeah.
I clogged my kitchen sink, guys, before I left.
I forgot to tell this story.
The plumber's coming in tomorrow, so they're supposed to
come today, but I was just like, they didn't have time for
today, so they're coming tomorrow.
I forgot about this story.
apparently it's been clogged for a while and I didn't
realize that because I realized the garbage disposal doesn't
work anymore um 10 minutes before I uh sorry five minutes
before uh I was supposed to go to my uber I was like trying
to like uh I was trying to put stuff in the garbage disposal
to blend it up and so and then it was like things weren't
going down that garbage disposal was not working
so obviously I was panicking and then it was sort of like I
was like maybe my poop were water and it just started
grabbing a sick and just poke it through it'll start working
again and it was so my sink was like half full and then
stuff wasn't going down the guy like nothing was work things
weren't going Like, wham, wham!
Thanks.
Nothing was going wham, wham!
In the sinkhole.
And I was, like, five minutes before I was supposed to...
Like, the Uber was five minutes before I was supposed to
arrive.
And I just left it there.
I was just like, I hope when I come back, the sink was
slowly drained through.
And it did!
I came back the sink was drained at least but I but that try
and I was like oh is it fixed you know maybe it fixed itself
and then uh and then I turned on the sink it's a very slow
drain let's just say The train is very, very slow.
So, so someone's coming over tomorrow to fix that.
I didn't have time to look into it.
I was literally, I was freaking out.
It was like five minutes before I had to go down for the
Uber.
And I was like, can't be late to my trip to the Bahamas.
And, um,
yeah so um hope the guy fixes it tomorrow that's yeah I was
like that's future dokey's problem and I'm future dokey uh
so they're coming in tomorrow to look into there's I was
trying to look for someone today but uh nobody was free
today um I I like try to find someone the day before I came
back just because like um you know just because like I want
to be sure I was back by then
um yeah don't worry it's gonna be fixed guys don't don't
worry everything will be okay cyber think of a super chat
thank you thank you how the hell do you keep breaking your
sink Think of the Super Chat, think of the thing.
Well, the thing is, I didn't fix it the last time.
It fixed itself.
And I guess it didn't really actually fix itself.
It didn't really actually fixed itself.
So, it was just something...
Because I didn't realize the garbage disposal technically
doesn't even work anymore.
I haven't used it in a while.
The last time I used it, when it fixed itself last time.
That was like...
a year ago, right?
So, that was the last time I actually used a garbage
disposal.
And, uh, yeah.
This is celebrated to get improved for my first apartment.
Congratulations, Brady!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Congratulations!
I'm super proud of you.
Oh, you're gonna have so much...
You're gonna have so much work to do.
Packing and moving and stuff.
It's the worst.
But I hope you enjoy your first apartment.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't do what I do.
do guys yeah plumber's gonna be very happy with me as a
customer i'm trying to think about what else what else
happened during um i don't know what to stream tomorrow most
like i want to play there's so many games i want to play i
know a lot of games were releasing uh while it was gone so
it was like everyone play uh let's see i wish there's a
couple of stuff but i was just i'm gonna play this when i
get back oh yeah there's like the new overwatch update and
everything with a new rank reset and stuff.
I'm going to check that out too.
Not this week though.
Where Lily Peach.
I was so surprised.
Like I found that out on the cruise web.
Oh yeah.
Those.
That too.
But Lily Peach is like the new character.
Demon or whatever her name is.
I was so.
I did not realize that was her.
I did not realize her voice could go that low.
It's crazy when they were like.
When it was revealed.
Like it's so weird.
Thinking that that's the voice it's coming out of.
You know what I'm saying?
Um.
Yeah, Lily Pichu is the voice of...
Yeah, she's the voice actor of Demon.
Yeah, like, and then there was a video of, like, the diva
voice actor with her.
Like, IRL, doing the voices.
And it's so...
Like, it breaks my brain seeing that.
She sounds...
Yeah, I did not realize that was her.
Oh, yeah.
I really want to play that Roblox...
uh the hospital roblox game you guys heard of that one um
where it was like it's like paper please but like for a
hospital and it's in roblox it's like paramour to paranormal
activity with paper please and you're in the hospital i
heard like it's like super popular right now in the yeah
animal hospital yeah yeah yeah i heard that game is like
really popular right now
um it does not look like a roblox game by the way like it
does not look like a roblox game at all the models are like
surprisingly like non-roblox like because it looks like it
reminded me of that game um what was it called the truck
moving animal game it were the the style of it looks like uh
easy delivery code You guys know what I'm talking about?
It looks like that game's like the art style.
Was it that?
Not.
It's like that.
What was it?
No, not that one.
It looks like the.
What's that game called?
It's like a meme where it's like a rabbit or a cat in a
spooky.
Okay.
Rabbit.
Scary game meme.
Is it a rabbit or a cat?
That gift.
You know that gift?
Oh, it is.
It looks like this.
it looks like this meme the art style but like in Roblox I
just thought it was like a scene game until I realized it
was on Roblox this meme
it looks like this like that's the art style of the game
um Abel thank you for super chat thank you thank you went to
jbbq for my birthday today delicious happy birthday so many
people's birthday let me dragonless birthdays today happy
birthday we had a great birthday thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you happy birthday to you happy
birthday to you happy birthday dear abel happy birthday to
you yeah happy birthday um i want to play that game and i
also want to play The one where you repair.
There's so many.
I have so many games on my wish list right now.
That I really want to play.
And also I'm going to finish the armor core.
Get the other two endings.
Because you guys said that.
It'll be really fast.
You better not be lying to me.
It better be fast.
And also actually go back to 007.
We're going to have to have a quick recap.
To remember what the fuck happened in that game.
Because I've been, I bought to this week, I want to play a
lot of like, I want to play like some 1-off games this week.
I don't want to play like series right now.
I just want to play 1-off.
Like I just got back from my vacation.
So I just want to chill a little bit and play some, like,
1-off games.
But next week, we'll go and look into finishing up some,
finishing up some of the series that we weren't able to
finish.
I'm sorry.
Lego Batman might
And then Who
Oh you're looking at any New FPS games You guys hear about
the extraction shooter Where you have to pay to extract Like
where you have to pay to play I saved it in my bookmark
Because I thought it was so fucking funny
What is it called?
There's apparently this new extraction shooter Um Where
Where what is where is it i saved it but um oh yeah rest in
peace the climat calamity mod rest in peace guys i don't
play terraria but like all my friends who played terraria
were really really sad apparently it's like what the best
mods um the best mod for terraria or some shit rest in peace
for those who don't know what happened um i think like for
the developer got out of it to be like maybe really bad, bad
people really, really bad people, let's just say
alright was it kids or crypto it's not crypto that's all
I'll say it's not crypto yeah that's might narrow things
down that might narrow things down for you all
right okay so the world's first real money shooter so
basically you have to pay one dollar to spawn earn one
dollar to per kill so you get kills per you get money per
kills and then there's like a risk mode range from 0.10
cents to ten dollars and you find real cash drops in maps
and extract them like what yeah it's a real like bro
cheaters are gonna have so much fun earning free money it's
like the world's first real money extraction cheater it's
backed by crafting wait really holy shit i don't know this
feels like something that's gonna last for like uh i feel
like that's something that's gonna last for like maybe like
a week there's no way how can it pay you maintain a positive
positive kd eluding straggle cash drop earn and sell skins
and that i don't know it sounds like it does sound like a
scam i'm just gonna say like cheat like how do you get what
about the hackers you know
yeah may the best cheater wins like cheat devs are gonna go
fucking wild with that
yeah you have to give them your payment information too how
are you gonna get paid
i feel like how are you gonna fuck are you gonna get you
have to give like your actual payment in like your actual
information you get you're gonna get docs you're gonna get i
i won't be surprised if this was vibe coded
sounds like something that's been vibe coded not gonna lie i
don't think there's a lot of big security oh did you hear
someone made it i saw this on uh twitter but someone made a
like a vtuber version of cameo and that was apparently i
don't know if it was vibe coded but the security was really
fucking bad bad and like a vtuber hacked into it some a
vtuber i saw it popped up because like they were like made a
call the person that hacked into it made a call-up post
being like hey the security sucks like i just got all this
information from your website because it was like a vtuber
cameo and legit this guy has access to everybody's like
personal information emails like ip's payment yeah yeah it's
like i warned them and then i guess they didn't like take
him see you know how like you know those hackers are like um
if you don't take me seriously i'm gonna fucking release the
data yeah yeah but apparently the security's fucking ass
that's the thing you gotta be really worried about with all
these new websites and stuff because like you're gonna
potentially have release if it's vibe coded i don't know if
it was by i don't think i don't know the the vtuber camio
website was vibe coder or whatnot but like it was not to be
like a lot of websites are now vibe coded so like you gotta
be very wary about any new websites out there i don't trust
a lot of like i don't trust joining a lot of like the newer
websites because like um Vibcodes now.
Like, no, there's no actual security anymore.
Something tells me, Doki, don't vibe with it.
What's vibe coding?
Vibcoding is where you use AI to code for you, so you just
be like, make me a game that, make me a website that is,
like, VTuber Camia website, and then I would like the UI to
be like this.
I would like this.
I would like the purchasing things to be like it's just that
and then the ai just mix it for you
yeah so you don't you're not actually coding yourself you're
letting me you just type in like oh i just want a website
like this i want this like i want this to be like that and
then the ai just codes it and you don't check what the ai
made so you're just like it looks good
you're just like it looks all right i mean it is what i
wanted visually wise I want it visually.
Let's not look at the security behind it, but like, it has
everything I want.
Yeah, so there's a lot of back doors and stuff, a lot of
back door entrances and everything.
It turns out I can access the website.
It's good enough.
That's I feel like a lot of stuff happened while I was gone.
I saw a lot of drama.
I was just like, I saw like a lot of drama and a lot of like
things exploding and I'm like and I was just like I'm on a
cruise Like everyone else was tweeting about drama and like
I'm not gonna talk about it because I was not obviously I'm
not involved So I don't want to talk I don't really want to
like touch on it because like I'm not part of it or anything
I'm just looking at the sidelines and I'm like people were
like you know a lot of like shit was happening on on Twitter
And online and I'm out here posting a picture.
It's like I'm in the Bahamas everybody like That's sipping
on my magnirita.
I'm fucking floating the ocean.
Oh, something exploded in the YouTuber community.
Here's a picture of a towel monkey.
By the way, the housekeeping made animals other than towels.
I posted a picture of that on Twitter.
It's having fun on the beach, guys.
Oh, yeah, look at this.
For those who haven't seen, I'm on a boat.
Look at this beautiful fucking monkey towel.
Yeah, I was like, I was like, read the...
I'm like, when I posted it, I was like, maybe I should have
read the room before I posted this tweet.
I was like, shit, something's going on in the YouTuber
community right now.
Hey, guys!
Look at this sick-ass towel monkey!
oh my god just living life
everything always happens when i'm on vacation yes it's like
world is burning i'm fucking i'm fucking petting a sea lion
oh yeah like i said sea lion was so god damn cute he was
like uh oh yeah by the way it's fucking i did not who would
have thought there's jellyfishes in the I didn't realize
there was a giant sign It got really paranoid Because like I
was in the It's floating in the ocean Also the sea lions are
so I think if you ever get a chance to Sorry I'm jumping
between both topics If you ever had a chance to Hang like do
like sea lion activities Like Me a sea lion or swimming with
sea lion Take that over the dolphins guys Really great
experience like Oh they're so cute Sea lion gave me a kiss
There was like a photo shoot moment where they like The sea
lion would give you a kiss or like hug you and stuff.
And I was like, ah!
Or like, you know, like put their head under your chin and
everything.
It's so cute.
They're so fucking cute.
Um, and they get to pet, yeah, they're the water doggos.
They get to pet him and everything.
And they're like swimming between your hands.
Oh, they're so cute.
You get, yeah, they give this little smooches and stuff.
Not like dolphins.
Dolphins are the sexual predators of the sea.
I don't trust them.
I...
I don't trust them at all.
Anyway.
The real.
What's I say?
Oh, yeah.
But anyway, I was like floating in the ocean.
And there was like kids next to me like, oh, I think I saw a
jellyfish.
I was like, constantly, there's no way there's jellyfish.
You know, I'm in the ocean.
I was like, those kids.
are so silly there's no way there's jellyfishes here i did
not care at all just oh also by the way there were fishes
swimming around around me so like um dream thank you for
super chat thank you thank you so like in my head i didn't
like process the fact that jellyfish live in the ocean uh
and then i got out of the ocean it was a giant ass sign that
was Like, be aware of jellyfishes.
I felt like I should have been definitely been more aware of
the jellyfishes.
I really should have been much more aware.
I was like, silly kids.
There's no jellyfish in the ocean.
Where did you think they live?
Outside of my ocean.
That's where I...
Because I thought the kids were fucking with me.
When they were like saying there was a jelly, you know, kids
being kids, but I think they actually saw a real jellyfish
now that I saw the sign Yeah, they're outside of my
vicinity.
They're like they're a myth
Yeah, not this specific ocean
But like in the past I was like I hate the beach because I
was like oh You know in the past I would say like oh I'm not
a fan of the beach, but I think like it I think I've just
been on the wrong beaches.
I would give the Bahamas would be my beach exception.
It was very nice.
It was actually very nice to just be like, except the salt
water.
I would say it.
Not a fan of the salt in the water.
I didn't try to dunk my head in the water or anything.
It was mostly just me like, just lounging in the water.
You know, like lounging above the water.
But it was still very relaxing.
yeah
just i'm not definitely not a fan of the salt content in the
water i did you guys know that salt water burns burns your
nose whoa yeah yeah gently floating in the tropical sea is
very nice that's why i like my brain is still there my brain
is still like in the ocean right now in the Bahamas floating
around.
All right, I think that's basically the recap.
That's the recap of my trip to the Bahamas.
It's great, though.
I've been traveling.
Unless you guys know I've been traveling a lot.
I've been flying a lot this year.
It's the most I've been flying.
I still have to fly.
I didn't go snorkeling.
I don't know.
I think it's the fear, the Steve Irwin fear, I think.
I think I was worried that my accidentally touch something
then then and then I'll die I think I think I think I have
the Steve Irwin fear of I don't want worry I'll touch
something yeah yeah but I will uh I will say uh I will be
flying again next week I think it's next week right I know
they're announcing it soon or yeah I'll be flying in next
week, but it'll be a short flight.
It's just I'll be gone for three days, and it's actually a
business trip this time.
But we only be gone for like three days.
And it's actually a business trip, and it's the it's going
to be announced soon-ish, I think like tomorrow or
something.
But I talked about it before what it is.
But I don't want to reveal this.
I talked about it before.
For those who watch my streams, you might know what it is
already.
But I don't want to talk it here now because they are
announcing it tomorrow.
I am very tired of flying.
But I do want to...
I'm very excited for this one.
It's not Korea.
It's in NA.
So don't worry about it.
But it's just that.
I think that's like...
That's the only...
I have another business trip flight I have to do.
But it's later on.
two months and two months away so but yeah um i won't be
gone for that long next week like i said it's only three
days and i there will be a stream within those three days
too so do not worry about that there will be a stream within
those three days so um it's not like i'll be like another
like vacation or anything because it is a business trip yeah
no i've been flying a lot i'm i'm getting a tide from all
the flights and everything but i have been having um a lot
of fun um doing all these projects and stuff related to if
it's a business trip and everything um you know but i did
need this vacation i did need this vacation a lot because oh
my god i was like i i was so burnt out i was so like burnt
out and tired uh before the cruise so i really needed like i
got my energy got
was definitely a good recharge for me and everything so i'm
glad i did took the time off
yeah is there anything else you guys want to ask me about
the trip i think i talked about everything about the trip
i'm pretty sure
favorite moment my favorite moment um the food food was
great like i said i did the buffet i think i could just live
off the buffet
and then you just live off the buffet I think the cruise is
just I will say it don't if you're going on a cruise just
don't spend any money on there's a lot of complimentary free
shit on the cruise the pay stuff is how they get you that's
how they farm you so and the casinos say the thing I regret
the most is just I didn't do I wish I did more of the free
activities that they had around um uh but like the buffet
the buffet is already really really good in general so just
go for the buffet like they had like they have everything uh
I don't know if I took any pictures of it um let me see if
there's any pictures that I took that didn't show it
Oh, let's see.
Like, there's free fruit.
There's free...
There's, like, a free sandwich place where they make you
sandwiches live.
There's, like, just...
Like, there's a bunch of restaurants that's just free.
You know?
I'll send you...
I'll send this one.
There's, like, jacuzzi's.
There's pools on the cruise.
And everything.
Just a good time.
Okay, I can show you guys this.
More pictures of the beaches.
There's free alcohol.
Um, it depends.
Uh, depends on where you're at.
There's some, uh, you might have to buy, okay, so.
I don't remember where, but there is, like, a particular
area where you can get, like, one free alcohol a day or some
shit.
Or you have to pay, like, the drink package.
Like, it was like, there was one.
one uh in the buffet all the the uh it's like one free drink
alcoholic drink a day or some shit and you want more than
that like you have to pay the drinking package and like okay
so I um I talked during like so there's like when you're
like when you depart on the cruise during like like beach
days so there's two beach days I and one of them there's
like a golf cart that takes you Closer to the beach and
obviously I waited for that.
I tried to walk to the beach the first time around not it
It's not it.
It was like a very long walk.
I was like I don't fuck with that So I started waiting for
the golf cart taxis I was just like this is a very I was
like I can walk this I was like this is a very long walk I
don't fuck with that.
It's like I'm I'm gonna take the golf cart any taxis into
the beach um anyway um talking to like one of the guys that
was doing this like uh he did not look that old he was like
50 plus year old he's very young in spirit uh with his
hawaiian string or anything and he like left his girlfriend
to walk because his girlfriend was like i'm gonna go walk
because there was a line for the taxis and he's like now i'm
taking the golf cart taxi and i was like and then i don't
know why he like struck a conversation with me and I was
like, didn't your girl, like, he was just, I was like, why
did you, I was like, why did you leave your girlfriend out
there?
And he's like, she'll get there.
She wanted to walk.
I was like, he was just like, she wanted to walk.
I'm not walking.
Anyway, he's like, yeah, I got, he was telling me how he got
the drink package.
And, um, and he's like, oh, I already paid it off.
Like, it already paid itself because he was like, just
chugging down, like, alcohol.
every day and stuff but it was like I remember the drink
package was expense I thought it was expensive I guess if
you're like just drinking alcohol every day I guess it does
pay for itself like but even like soft drinks like soft
drinks you have to pay for it like you have to get the drink
package for it and I was like no I'm just gonna go to the
buffet and get like use a refill and water and apple juice
there's apple juice orange juice lemonade and water I I'm
fine with that.
Like, I'll drink my...
And my one free alcoholic drink.
Yeah.
Like, I'm cool with that.
Oh, yeah.
I'll show you guys more pictures.
Free...
Exactly!
Free juice!
Fuck yeah!
Let's go!
Oh, I love this photo.
There's this photo I took.
That I thought was really funny.
Guess what?
My ship's bigger.
That's the context I'll give you.
When you see this photo.
Yeah.
My ship is bigger.
Guys, she tells you not to worry about.
Yeah, you want to compare ships, guys?
You want to compare.
See, this is what I mean.
mean this is also what I mean the line the pathway to the
beach I don't fuck with I waited for the taxi I mine was the
bigger ship yeah you want compared sizes yeah ship waving
it's not the size of
captain it's not about the size it's about the movement of
the ocean all right so more scenery more beach views yeah
it's a nice beach guys and i don't i think this was day one
of the beach with the water park which i could not go which
i could not do for the safety of me and and everyone The
Titanic was big too.
It's very beautiful.
Very nice view.
Yeah, I wish I could have done the water part.
I think that's the one thing I regret.
Because there was a blood moon.
There's free ice cream.
Free drinks.
Free food.
I asked for it.
Pay $10 for the shittiest escape room of my life, but I
couldn't even escape in.
But we're on the icon of the seas that you booked that
two-story cabin that slides instead of stairs in it.
I think it was Super Chat Crimson.
Thank you, thank you.
I legitimately don't remember what ship I was on.
I did not pay it.
I will be.
I did not pay attention.
I was like, Bahamas, here I come.
I
I was like, I'm ready for the Bahamas, baby.
All right, what are your question stories you guys want to
hear about?
I only remember, yeah, my ship was bigger than all the other
ships.
Apparently, there's an even bigger ship, too, from what I
sold, from the art gallery people.
Apparently, there was an even bigger ship that just came
out.
is the biggest one
all right I need to get water I'll be back guys I need some
water right now I need hydrate
surprisingly did not get seasick I did not feel the motion
at all wait I'll be back though
oh how I hit my knee Ow!
I hit my knee on my desk.
Alright, I'm back.
Ow!
I'm trying.
Ah!
You know when you hit yourself, you're like, you gotta
scream the pain out.
Uh, Rana, AK.
Uh, thank you.
Thank you.
Um, what was I gonna say?
Oh, I didn't get seasick.
I'm surprised enough.
I did not feel the ocean of the, the motion of the waves.
Hell, I think it's just because I don't get motion sickness.
At all.
Um, I told a story before.
But I've been on ferry rides and stuff.
And, uh, not on cruise.
This is my first cruise.
But.
I do not get seasick at all.
And I know about this.
Because, um, during a school field trip.
Um, you know, put the door.
I think it's because, like.
Uh, blah blah blah.
I think it's because, like, uh.
I didn't turn out like a big air con when I left.
Um, but anyway.
Um.
Uh.
We had to go on a ferry ride for a school trip and there was
only a everybody was getting seasick except for Six of us
five or six of us and we were like It was so funny.
Well, not for the people that are seasick that So the rest
of the class except for five the six of us were not seasick
including me I wasn't one I was the lucky few that was not
seasick and then we're like what we're like We're just like,
you know, it's it's like we're the survivors, you know, the
and the non-in-fail.
So we all grouped up together because all the people that
were safe, like had to sit, had to be like quarantined to
like a specific section.
Well, there was no need to quarantine them, but I guess
because like, you know, so they were given like the throw-up
bags and everything.
And five to six of us, we just huddled up and just played
Uno.
We just played card games.
We had like, someone had a deck of cards and we were like
the, we were like the survivors, you know?
We were the immune, the immune.
And then so we were just like, one of us had a pack of Uno
cards and a pack of cards.
And we were just playing card games while we were waiting
for the ferry ride to end, like to take us to the
destination.
Like, yeah.
So we were just chilling there.
And then the other side was just like all the other students
were just throwing up.
and so we're like we're like playing fucking card games and
playing oh no i don't remember i was like i was like in
middle school i don't fucking remember if i won or not i
just knew i wasn't infected we were actually we were part of
the immune and the immune survivors
yeah everyone else was throwing up we're just playing
fucking cards
because we're like oh they're really like okay the She was
like, all right, these are the students that are not
throwing up.
That are okay.
So, like, hey, what do you guys want to do?
I got packed with cards.
Let's play.
At the back.
Like, we're like, we're like, what do we do at the best
time?
You know, what are we fucking going to do?
We're like, we still have like 40 minutes left of this ferry
ride.
What the fuck are we going to do?
There was no internet connection on the ferry, by the way.
We had to do what we...
Gotta do what we gotta do.
You know, I did not get seasick at all.
But yeah, like, I think, like, next time I ever do a cruise
again, um, I definitely want to do more of the activities
that was offered on the cruise, and also a water park.
I want to do a water park and more of the, because I didn't
do the, there was, like, rock climbing and stuff.
Like, there was rock climbing.
There was, like, other shows, um, stuff that wasn't, like,
corny as hell.
I wish I, uh, and stuff, like, uh, I wanted do the adult
karaoke i wanted to like uh because i never done karaoke
like you know it was like a bunch of drunk people like some
of them were not like the best singers but everyone was like
fucking having so much fun i was there watching everyone was
so having so much fun and everything i was like oh i've been
so fun to like sing at least one song there um but i was
like you know i i when i came in it was everyone already
like um um we're already like signups were already full and
everything but even when the signups were full i still like
stayed just so i you know enjoyed the environment and like
the the fun vibe of everything but definitely i know how uh
i know how to spend less money on the cruise like i know i
have to i know what to do to do uh i definitely would do
more of the free stuff there instead of the paid options.
But yeah, that was the cruise life.
One of the five Asians there.
I remember there was a lot.
Apparently it was like, there was like one of the staff was
telling me, because they were like, guess how many people
were on the cruise?
And I was like, I don't know.
5,000.
Like, it's more than that.
It was like, I think like, ah, what was it?
Um,
trying to remember if i wrote it down i think oh okay i
think it was like 10 000 plus uh people on that cruise or
something i think it was like 2k were just staff alone on
the ship it did not feel like a 10k by the way did not feel
like there was 10 000 people on the ship by the way It did
not feel like that Because there was a lot of stuff to do
Everywhere There was a lot of stuff to do everywhere Yeah
The five Asians on the 10k And 2k of And then there's 2k
staff Like crew members Crew members on the ship I swear I
think I counted I counted guys Just because I was like Same
hat Because I was just like, I didn't realize it was such a
non-Asian thing to do, I guess.
Like, I don't know how I was to describe it.
It was like a lot of, it was just a lot of like white people
on the cruise.
And I didn't realize it was just not a very Asian thing to
do.
Maybe it was just that cruise in particular.
Maybe.
But there was like five of them.
us there at least there's five of us there you know it
was nice though it was nice experience
but i don't want i don't think i'll do it like regularly but
it was just something nice to experience at least once in
your life type deal
and i got like you know i got some cool souvenirs from it
too i got muhammad ali's boxing trunks because i was It's
like, why not?
Signboxing jokes, too.
Because why not?
I think it's just a cool thing to have.
I mean, it's like, you know, it's like a Stan Lee thing.
You know?
Like, you know how like...
Because like, back in the day...
You know how like back in the day...
every sad also sadly had like a shit like would autograph
anything and everything but he's like you know he's he's
he's passed he's passed away but it's still like a great
piece to have just because it's like um that it's just
because like you know he's not signing anymore you know so
it's like just a something like a nice memorabilia to have
yeah Because, like, back then, I remember when he was still
alive.
Like, it was very easy to get a Stan Lee autograph because
he would sign a lot of stuff.
I would, like, I'd own something from Stan Lee one day.
I just, like, collecting weird shit.
I think, like, how people are surprised whenever I, like,
have something weird.
I don't know, weird is, like, the right term.
I like collecting unique things.
I like
collecting, like, unique things or, like, random
collectibles.
Like, I fucking, every time I visit somewhere, I buy
something.
Buy something, something unique as, like, a momento of the
trip.
For the cruise, that was Muhammad Ali's boxing trunks,
because I was, like, that's cool.
fucking American eagle and a fucking fucking bald eagle
statue holding the American flag whose art, whose sculpture
has works in the White House.
Because like, guys, I'll be like, guys, you see the
sculpture?
Guys dead, but he...
Guys dead, but his work is in the White House though.
Like, literally in the Oval Office, by the way.
I...
Oh, shit.
The Scooby-Doo print, which I, they threw, I, I paid $50 for
it, but they gave it to me for free.
Um, did not, by the way, some of you aren't, like, I did not
have to pay for shipping or any, framing or anything.
They threw all, I think because I, they saw my channel.
I didn't, I gave them my channel because I was just like,
they're like, what do you do?
And I was just like, oh, I'm content creator because they're
like, where do you have the money?
you know and I was just like there's like one where moments
where I was just like oh I'm a content creator just to see
if I get see just you know and then no they saw my channel
they saw my channel and everything they're subscribed to the
channel too so I didn't have to pay for like framing
stripping and stuff and then
And, like, and, uh, and they, uh, uh, fuck.
And then they threw, like, I bid on the Scooby-Doo print.
You have that for free.
I was like, sweet, nice.
I thought, because I thought it was pretty funny.
I thought the Scooby-Doo print was pretty funny.
Let me see if I could find it.
Um, I don't know.
I took a picture of it.
Let me see.
It was inside the Scooby-Doo house.
I'm trying to see if I could find it.
The exact print itself.
It was a sick-ass Scooby-Doo.
I should have taken a picture of it.
It was me versus a kid.
The kid was like...
I won it.
And I was like, too bad you don't have $50, kiddo.
That's right.
Your mama didn't give you enough allowance for this picture.
And I didn't even have to pay for it in the end.
They threw it in for free.
That's right, kids.
Should have asked your mama for $50.
And I didn't even...
Yeah.
Probably hoping to get promotion from Doki as a content
creator should forget the ship's name.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Prepare to lose child.
That's right.
My Scooby-Doo won it fair and square.
I didn't take a picture of it.
I should have.
I should have taken a picture.
I was so excited.
I was so excited to win it.
I didn't even take a picture of it.
I forgot.
I was so excited, okay?
I was like, oh, shit.
My Scooby-Doo.
I didn't.
They're shipping it over.
They're shipping everything over.
Let's see.
I think I found the title of it.
I'm trying to see.
I found the receipt of the ship.
Because you're like, oh, we're shipping it now.
I think it's this one.
Oh, I think it's this one.
I found it.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure it's this one.
How much is it?
Sold for sold date.
It's from 2002.
I got this one.
Yeah, this is the one I got.
I thought this was.
print was sick as hell so there was like they had two um
they had this one like there's this other one that was more
of a classic but i thought mine was more unique and that's
why i bid it on that one um
oh shit it's for like 400 bro i got for 50 let's go okay
let's see where did i save it
I think these are normally like prints.
They're not like one-to-one shit.
Because like, okay, so this is what, because I researched
about this, this is about art gallery and auctions and
stuff.
Even the print is considered like, you know, like, oh,
number 200 out of blah, blah, blah, blah.
But like, you want to buy one-to-ones more so.
Like, like how art galleries and stuff, like auction stuff,
like you have to want to avoid prints um and like uh prints
and like reprints because if they're not like the original
one to one even with numbers number like oh number blah blah
out of blah blah you tend to have to avoid if it's like a
painting or something yeah it's not like not something like
super unique because what's stopping them from printing more
like you get what i'm saying That's why I bought a statue
because I was like The statue was Like I felt like a statue
Is cooler because it's like a physical thing Versus like
Like even though like work was actually put Into like making
it Versus just copy and paste printing It out like That's
why I bought a fucking statue Because I thought more More
work was put into making a statue Versus just Um Versus just
printed it out in a printer.
Like, even if it was on, like, a canvas paper or some shit.
And the guy's dead, too, so.
Like, he was alive when he made it.
So that's why I got it.
He was alive when he made this statue.
Alright, this is the print I got.
I thought I was...
I thought this was a cool-ass print.
That's why I got it.
It's framed, too.
Yeah, there was the other one, which was, like, the classic
Scooby-Doo one.
But I thought it was, like, you get to see that a lot.
I thought, and the other one was more unique.
I don't see that artwork a lot, too.
I took that from a child.
I opened a kid for that.
This is the other one that was put up for all.
But I didn't get that one because I felt like this was like
a classic.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, like you see this one a lot everywhere, but I don't
see.
I've never seen that other one before.
You see this one a lot, but I've never really seen this one
before.
So I got that one.
Mama, she's giving you more than $40.
That was my, that was the Scooby-Doo one I got.
yeah this one is boring this one this one is like a little
everywhere you look at there's something cool and new
the thing is his mom was next to him his mom didn't give him
more than that kid's mom was next to him
should have begged your mom for 10 more dollars still
wouldn't outbid me actually no i would gonna stop at 50.
I was like 50 is the furthest I was gonna go.
It was a big one too.
It wasn't like a small print or anything.
It was like a giant print.
That's why I was just like I was willing to get it just
because I thought it was cool.
I like to... Someone said what's the weirdest thing I've...
What's the most unique thing I've ever collected?
I think Muhammad Ali's signature was definitely the most
unique thing I've bought.
But... I'm trying to think.
I have the Hamilton, I told you guys, like, if I go to,
like, a really cool event or a really cool thing, I
literally have the Hamilton, I have Book of Mormon slash
Hamilton poster signed by the original cast, both of them.
So, like, you know, like, I have both posters.
They were both signed by the original cast.
Like, you know, Book of Mormon had Josh Gadd and Hamilton
had Lin-Manuel.
I have those posters.
That was when I was in New York City.
um when i saw the original broadway um broadway uh
production of it from the original cast members um what
weird shit do i have i have uh like i said i have like a
replica deathbunk helmet i only have gimuel um because i i
gimuel is my favorite and i have i told you guys about this
before but deathbunk did a art gallery a very long time ago
and it was like the first artwork collect artwork i've ever
owned like a actual canvas collection i've ever owned with
that punk they've only done this once where they
collaborated with a lot of really famous artists and it was
called the gauntlet gallery in san francisco
um and i own one of their it was a reprint it was a canvas
reprint it's not the original i showed Oh my god.
It even linked my Twitter.
I tweeted this last year too.
I googled art gallery Daft Punk and my photo of the canvas
shows up.
Yeah.
That's fucking crazy.
My photo that posted on Twitter shows up.
this.
This is literally my very first art gallery.
It's on a canvas too.
So this is what it looks like.
This is what the artwork looks like.
And it was like a, you know, it was a limited thing.
So it was like one out of blah, blah, blah, blah.
I don't remember which number of mine was.
But it wasn't the, obviously it's not the original painting.
That would be like thousands of dollars.
But I have the canvas reproduction of it.
But it's also numbered.
So this is what the artwork looks like um i thought it was
like one of the most beautiful paintings i saw in the art
gallery and that's why i bought it because i really loved
like it was just really beautiful and it was on a canvas too
so i own that and i also own i'm trying i own a lot of weird
shit i just i think like recently i started collecting more
weird stuff just because like You know, I have disposable
income now.
Like, more disposable income, I guess.
Was it 1064?
I don't remember.
It was a long time ago.
Trying to remember what other weird, like, weird unique
stuff that I have in my collection.
I want to do a... I want to do a hand cam stream.
I'm showing you guys everything.
All the weird stuff I own.
And just, like, showing it on the camera one day.
All of it's just mostly boxed up, too, as well.
They're, like, mostly boxed up.
Because, like, I was like, oh, whenever I have a place, I
can finally display it all.
Rice, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I hope that once you get that house, you have a room full of
your random...
Yeah, that's what I was hoping for.
I have a room full of just random stuff that I collected.
have a lot trying to think right now uh i'm trying to think
at the moment
i mean i could look at my phone i take pictures of a lot of
weird stuff too let's see let me look through my phone
oh yeah and then when i was in when i was in uh uh korea
they gave me a lot of like i told you guys right i showed
you guys the t1 uh um faker trading cards that you can't get
anymore i got like that too some of them are like gifts and
stuff too
all right let me go like all the way back and start looking
oh
yeah let me see oh i found pictures of like the book of
mormon stuff
oh this is i have like i forgot i have this i went into the
un building too i have like uh okay i did i participated in
uh UN a long time ago and I was pretty good at it to to the
point in where in university was the university I don't
remember I got invited to do to be part of like biggest
model UN conference back then that's when I was smart on
Back when I was a head delegate.
I was the head delegate.
I always debated about telling this story.
But I was the head delegate of the committee I was
representing.
And...
And so we had to go to the actual United Nations building.
And so, so from, I just saw photos of it.
And I was like, oh my gosh, that was a while ago.
You know, the delegate of blah, blah, blah.
Oh, I'll tell you this story.
Okay, I'll tell you this story one time.
This is the same, same, this is when I was the health
delegate, too, of, like, taking care of, like, the, you
know, like, making sure everybody sent in their position
papers and everything.
it was a lot of responsibility um uh but yeah so uh you know
uh i was invited to do the model u.n conference to do the
model union conference as the head and represent and be the
head delegate of our committee and we had to go to the
actual u.n building where we debated stuff within the actual
you uh like where we had a chance to debate and do the
opening ceremony with the security what was it called oh my
gosh it's been so long with the secretary where the
secretary general at that time i don't remember who the
secretary general was at that time but the secretary general
yeah in new york city uh where the secretary general did the
opening ceremony and the opening speech and we get to sit
there in the actual u.n um the u.n
room with the you know the giant podium with a fucking green
colored giant podium and everything so you know that's when
you get to go to the u.n building you know when they sort of
used to be able to have power i'm not gonna go get into that
i'm not get too much into it when
Um, now I get too much into that right now.
When was that?
Um, anyway.
Okay, so I have a souvenir from there.
Secretary General at that time.
I don't know where it is.
It was basically I had them sign something a very long time
ago.
I don't know where it is anymore.
And I also have like when you're a head delegate, you get a
special jacket that that's cut like just for you.
That's just like just for you.
And it's like an official like United Nations jacket.
So I have that.
I used to wear that jacket all the time because i was like i
i don't know you know you're like hang on yeah i was the
head delegate so i used to wear that yeah i was at the
united nations like you know like i was what's that word uh
what's that word called when you're looking i don't say eat
like i have a high ego or anything but uh i guess to flex
about it like yeah i just thought Just a, yeah, a snob.
Just a bit of a snob there.
Yeah, yeah.
He signed what's in the actual United Nations building.
Pretentious.
Yeah, I think pretentious isn't that good word for it.
So I do have that.
Okay, so funny story.
I always debate about...
I do have funny stories about it.
But, like, funny story about this.
is that while I was head delegate one of the delegates in my
committee hooked up with the chair she hooked up with the
chair of by the way we were partners for this by the way we
were partners in that committee I don't even remember which
committee it was your partners in that committee she hooked
up with the fucking chair of the committee and also did it
in the committee room
and i was just like i and then when she told me the story i
was like i work i god the desk i work at So for those who
don't know UN lingo, the chair is the head speaker or the
head committee session runner of the session.
So they'll be the ones using the hammer being like the
committee is in session or like the resolution has passed or
like I yield time to like they'll be like I yield time to
the chair.
Like, that's who the chair is.
Like, that's the main guy that, uh, basically runs the
session and stuff.
Like, they have the hammer, basically.
Uh, defective.
Thank you for the one give this shit.
Thank you.
And it was, like, late at night, and they got caught by the
security, apparently.
And she, they had to, like, drink.
And I was like, are you fucking kidding me?
I was just like, why do you have to tell me this?
During the session, by the way, she told me this.
while I was like working on our paper because we were
partnered up.
So she told me this while we were, it was like, hey, oh my
God, I hooked up with the chair.
I'm like, I'm, oh my gosh.
Like, I was like, oh, that's cool.
That's good for you.
Like, I don't know what, what do I say?
I'm writing a resolution paper, like about some fucking
issue that was going on at that time.
And good for you.
And she's like, we did it in the committee room.
And I was like, on this table that I'm working.
I was like, yeah, I was like, I, why,
and by the way the story doesn't end there we were we share
the room together we share a room together because um
because tmi by yeah tmi by the way by the way that guy i
don't know he's a judge somewhere
smart man by the way he's I don't know you know he had a
plan he's like he wants to be he's he's a judge somewhere
now I don't know he's he's a very smart man maybe I won't be
surprised if he's a politician at now I will not be
surprised Anyway, anyway, so, so, um, was not the end of the
story because we share a room, a little bit of foreshadowing
there, and then, oh my god, oh my god, she's a very smart
woman too, by the way, she's very smart, she's like, she's
very pretty, she knows she's very pretty, and she knows
She's very smart.
Guys, her name was, her name is, sorry, she's a Jade.
Her name is Jade.
Like, you know, you know a Jade somewhere in your life.
There's a Jade in everyone's life.
There's a Jade in everybody's life.
Anyway.
I remember...
Well, I was working on a resolution.
I think it was like lunch break or whatever.
And then she...
And then like lunch break was about to end.
And then she came down to help me finish up the resolution.
And she was like...
Oh.
We hooked up again.
And I was like, alright.
I don't know what else to say.
And she was like, we did it.
in the bed.
And I was like, our bed?
Our bed.
She's like, don't worry, I put towels.
I was like, it's so what?
I was just like,
bed yeah does that make it any better I was like all right
housekeeping better change those sheets before I come back
up I was like bro I that's not a good room i think i i'm
pretty sure not think i would like to i would like to live
in the world that housekeeping did i try not to think too
hard about it but i assume housekeeping did indeed change
the bed sheets before i came back to the room i no they're
freaky they were fucking freaky they like started dating
after that and they oh my god they were so freaky like i
swear to god they Like, I don't know why she tells me these
stories.
I guess, I don't know.
Like, I never discouraged her.
So, I didn't tell her to stop.
But they've hooked up in a fucking elevator.
Like, they're fucking freaky.
They are in the elevator.
And everything.
I guess, yeah.
She needs someone to tell this to you.
Apparently I'm that someone, guys.
There's cow.
I don't think they cared.
I don't even think they care, guys.
What a lot.
How did that make you feel?
Thank you for the free therapy session, guys.
But yeah, anyway, those are some of the stories I'll tell.
Imagine she is watching right now.
Oh, hope she's enjoying life.
Honestly, I don't know, I just, like, have a, I just have a
lot of, like, fun, unique things that I own.
I'm sorry you know so much about our activities.
I'm sorry we know so much about our...
If I had to know, you have to know, too.
Sharing is caring.
We now have to know this together.
Next, see, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
now we are united with this knowledge
it's like we're united with the story
oh my god i still have like i have like the the head
delegate um i even had like business cards made too oh my
god it was like it was like God, I was such a nerd.
God, I was such a...
Oh, yeah, by the way, we won Distinguished Delegation, too,
by the way, while I was head delegate.
That was how much of a fucking nerd I was.
I do.
I have a picture of me holding the...
the uh the uh the certificate and everything where we we won
distinguished delegation which means we were one the
delegations that had like like that did really really well i
was a god damn nerd
but i have like pictures of like oh my god i'm just like
looking at i was like god damn almost stuffed you in a lock
right now I look how far you have fallen down dokey I am
happier let's just say I am a happier person now I take
those bro okay my my teammate my partner in the committee
although she was She was very very smart like she like I
will I try not to judge her For a fucking freaky ass
behavior, but at least she got the work done like what she
does in her pastime is
She as long as she gets her work done She just has other
freaky pastimes
That is...
Oh, she got it done.
Try to see what else I have.
I'm trying to see, like, anything cool I own.
Like I said, I have to, like, dig stuff out, I guess.
To, like, remember, like, just to...
Because, like I said, I collected a lot of shit over the
years.
So I need to, like, dig things out.
Oh, yeah, I own that.
I own that, too.
Oh, I have one of these.
Okay, so I don't know which one I have.
But, um, I don't know if she still does this.
But there was an artist.
Let me see if I can look it up.
I know I own one of them because she does like...
I don't know if she still does them because this was a long
time ago.
Uh...
Thing is, like, what is it called?
dioramas.
I saw it in my camera feed.
Oh, it's like, basically they look like this.
Terraria dioramas.
So I own one of them, but I don't remember which one I have.
I need to find it.
It's like in storage or some shit.
I don't know if she's still making...
Because this was like the original person that...
I know a lot of people copycat it later on.
But I don't know if the original artist still makes these.
But I Google this.
I don't remember which Pokemon I have.
But I have something like this.
If you guys ever seen them.
This is like something that's super popular.
Like she was a really popular artist that made them.
I know there's a lot of copycats now that do them.
But she was like the first one that made these.
And I would like follow her Twitter.
And like she would do like openings and stuff.
And then like they would get sold out so fast back in the
day.
And I managed to get one of them from her.
I think it was, it might have been, I'm trying to remember.
Actually, it might have been like a Sylveon, I think.
It was like, it was a really cute character.
That's all I could remember.
It was a cute Pokemon.
And she would do, I remember owning one of them.
That bot.
Because it was so hard to get to, because she would do like,
like, she would like put it up.
Like, she would be like, I will put this up on the Etsy, and
you better get them.
And then it's gone.
So you would have, like, one...
We would have, like, a one-to-two-minute window to grab the
one you want in time.
And I own one of these from her.
I don't know if she still makes those.
Because it was a long time ago.
But I know there's a lot of copycats now.
Yeah, the moment...
Like, she would do, like, an advanced opening.
She would do an advanced opening.
So she'll let everybody...
know in advance and then like everyone will just refresh the
store until it shows up and then you just grab the one you
want the most because you can only buy like you normally
people could only get one because the demand was so high
um but um
oh my god i once i saw uh was it let's see
for the original cat ear headphones.
Does anyone remember those?
Was it called Accent Wear?
Oh my god, I just saw it in my album.
I was one of the original Kickstarter backers for the cat
ear headphones of Accent.
It was Accent Wear?
Oh man.
What a shit show.
I told you guys, just so you guys know.
I was an OG backer.
The ones that are the ones that was supposed to.
Was like basically the ears were it was so uncomfortable by
the way.
It was not comfortable at all.
They were wore it one time and I was done.
I was like this shit sucks.
Yeah they sold the brand.
They sold the company after it failed.
Yoki is the only one here who could go on the bliss cruise
and then not participate because Captain thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you It was like very
uncomfortable very heavy and just not it And my friend one
of my friends she she she ordered three because she wanted
each color
She convinced me to back it too beg my mom I was just like
ma'am please can I can I back can I please use your card the
back I really wanted can I please please please please can I
have it I really want it it's so cool it's like a cat ear
headphone I wear it all the time I but wore it one time I
had to beg my mom for it too regrets Begged my mom for it.
Used it one time.
Absolutely regret.
I mean, I have like custom keyboards and stuff.
Like...
Oh, I have like...
Let's see.
It was not a very practical headphone.
They look pretty, but it was not practical at all.
all right i think that's everything i can show you guys i'm
like i'm actually just looking through all my uh my photos
and stuff just to go through memory lane i was so like i was
all about the aesthetic and everything too back in the day
oh my god now i don't i think it's just because like i won't
have like an actual now i'm way too
I just want, like, the most optimal build, the most optimal
keyboard, the most optimal Desmat and mice now, but then
this is me back then.
I just want things to look pretty.
I didn't have, like, a gaming mouse pad.
This is what my setup used to look like.
It was, like, when was this?
This is my old setup.
This was 2021.
This was my setup in 2021.
Yeah, so I had like a custom keyboard, custom, uh, what's it
called?
Custom, um, what's that cable?
Custom painted.
This was a custom painted, uh, G Pro Wireless.
And then custom keyboard, had that customly, I paid someone
to custom build this for me.
um uh and have it shipped over and then got this desk mat to
match everything else yeah this was my setup back then now
it's like not as aesthetically pleasing
i just use a wooden keyboard now
i would i would have a custom painted mouse i would get a
custom painted mouse again but like the one i use is the pro
x2 super strike and they're so hard to get that like none of
the custom painted websites that would paint your mouse um
they don't offer these because they're so hard to get like
the mouse i'm using right now because they're like the most
optimal gamer mouse and they're too hard to they're like too
in demand you can't you can't really order it which is very
frustrating they're too rare for customization because it's
like I always customize my mice
anyway that's my vacation oh my god you have for four hours
sorry but I had fun hanging out with you guys I always have
fun hanging out oh you guys enjoyed my little Bahamas
vacation recap and hanging out with me and um just you know
just chilling you get keyboard ASMR it's not really an ASMR
I mean does it sound as pretty they're not like you know
that it's just this they don't sound pretty they don't sound
like you're they don't sound like the like there's wood on
it or something like i don't know how to explain it like
when you get used like custom keyboard there's like a
particular sound to them this is the this is how my keyboard
sounds because it's a wooden keyboard um wu ting um they're
like optimized to be like pressed super fast and everything
so they don't have like have the aesthetic sound from
keyboard ASMR that you're used to.
Yeah.
They're for gaming.
It's not, yeah, Thawkey.
Yeah, like, I'm like, like, you know, it's like, it sounds
like it sounds like wood, hammering wood, I guess, for like,
if you want to, like, the keyboard ASMR, I guess.
It's not like the ASMR switches and everything.
but yeah that's my vacation I had a great vacation I'm fully
locked in now I really needed it I really really needed that
vacation and now I'm fully locked in so there's lots of
stuff to look forward to next see thank you super chat thank
you thank you thanks so much for the chill stream doki I
missed this and I'm glad for such a nice opportunity for
this full summer outfit yeah and give it the super chat next
see thank you thank you yeah fine we are back here in summer
in the summer again, just as summer about to end.
Oh yeah, I know some people were waiting for me to post the
references or the screenshots of the Eepie Bird outfit, but
I'm still waiting on Celia to finish the edits of
everything, because I want to make sure, like, when I post
it, it's, like, you know, the finalized version of, like,
everything.
So, I'm still waiting on Celia to finish doing the little
fixes for it, and adding nail polish and everything, and
then I'll post it.
We're just waiting on that.
um anyway guys i'm gonna head off now tomorrow will be a
stream i just gotta figure out what i want to play tomorrow
um most likely i think i might play restory because i want
to play something i just want to play some one-off games
this week but anyway guys as always everybody stay hydrated
posture check oh yeah i'll update okay oh neemy couldn't get
in i didn't receive a message about it but i'll update it um
let's see all right Alright, I'll go update the server.
I didn't realize they updated.
Let's see.
When did they...
Fuck with servers, guys?
Yeah, I didn't receive a...
Message about it, so I'll update it now.
Did they update it today?
This morning?
Alright, I'll update it.
Oh, last night?
Alright, it's being updated.
updated now.
Alright, as always, everybody, say hi, join the posture
check, get up, and move around to get that blood flowing.
Stay up for me, head to bed, guys, you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Thanks for hanging out with me today.
We're back again, baby.
Yeah!
I hope you guys enjoyed all the stories and everything.
Bye, everyone.
Bye.
oh secret ending because i realized i never showed the
picture about the muhammad ali boxing trunks so i was just
like oh that was the one thing i forgot
secret ending well i'm just gonna show the one i posted on
twitter it's not really anything new for those who don't
follow me on twitter because i know some of you guys don't
don't use twitter but basically this is the muhammad ali
boxing shorts trunk and this is like one of the auctioneers
hand that helped me hold it so this is it it was really
funny because the day I bid on this it was a day that it was
on beach day so like everyone was obviously on the beach so
there was only a handful of us that stayed to do the auction
stuff so I just won by default.
I just won by default.
Because no one, like, you know, it was just like a handful
of us there.
Everyone else was on the beach.
So, I actually went to the auction.
And I was like, I'll do the, I'll go to the beach after
this.
Because I wanted, I never been to an auction before.
So I wanted to experience it and see what that was like.
And I was like, I take those.
Yeah.
That's like first bid Yeah Anyway Bye everybody Bye Worth
it, yeah Worth it, bye guys